there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock alright here we are it's us
again yeah as episode 180 right before
the end of the world
pandemic over China's brewing man this
is like day two or three it's gonna be
just like right out of a stand never
have Stephen King book this habit we all
gonna die it's already here some day
it's already here yesterday I'm not
worried about it I'm just gonna stay
indoors
they obviously try to scare the crap out
of these like remember it was bird flu
and then it was swine flu it's like yeah
a lot of people die from it but it's
like they they kind of make like a huge
deal about everything and then like it's
just kind of like a wet fart like
nothing okay I'll um you know just
remember that all you know all uh all
right to your mom okay I don't never
can't tell you know but yeah so the show
today we've been I would wanted to talk
about this [ __ ] for a long time this
is carl panzram yeah yes k he's piece of
work who man this is kind of like he's
kind of like when we did the show about
kuklinski yeah this dude is kind of like
the early 20th century version of that
yeah he liked he liked Raven and little
boys though he raped pretty much
everybody a man man boys cops
just killing people like
indiscriminately yeah he just really no
real reason yeah he just really seemed
like the weird thing about him is that
he doesn't seem in the sense of like a
sexual sadist type of serial killer even
though he did rape most of his victims
as well it seemed like the reason for
doing that was just like power or to
like humiliate them like he wasn't doing
it like to get off really I don't
well we'll get into a minute you know he
had been raped from from early on us
yeah so that was just his his way of it
you know he said it was his way of like
asserting dominance yeah over somebody
else but he did enjoy it yeah I mean he
was just probably one of the most
misanthropic criminals I've ever read
about just like some of the quotes from
him are just kind of yeah amazing yeah
he was like born in late 18-hundreds
he's just a big ol german kid he was
like six feet tall weighed about 200
pounds yeah parents came from Austria
he's kind of like he was kind of like
the evil version of Arnold he's about
the size of Arnold you know what you
know eat that he called and he probably
had that same damn accent it you know
it's funny that it's funny that you
should say that because earlier today I
was listening to um last podcast on the
left and they actually did like a very
long like a three-part series on carl
panzram and they called him both the gay
Conan the Barbarian okay yeah and the
living embodiment of a Nick Cave song
yeah particularly stagger Lee what do
you know what they were talking about
okay but um so they like separately sang
part of that but it's like I thought it
was very funny because um part one of
the show about him I like that they
titled it a bit of a grouch yeah kind of
maybe shout outs or anything like that
um just one shout out to a new patron
that we have may see so hey they're
amazing okay thank you very much for
what you're supposed to be doing this
show right they always use new patrons
people yeah man that's like you know
we're doing four shows a week now and
they're extra long yeah we have been
doing much [ __ ] out of you people can
obtain this [ __ ] are you people I'm
probably gonna do them personally I'm
pregnant do impressions I'm pregnant do
voices I don't know maybe even you know
we might get we might get a [ __ ]
visit from Dennis there's no telling
what could happen I feel like Dennis
probably needs to weigh on this issue
because this guy and you know not only
this but it's
like a crazy [ __ ] story yeah like
remember I told ya I was like watching a
documentary about him like early today
or you search yeah I was doing all the
research about it and it's like I just
this made me like laugh really hard
somebody in the comments like on YouTube
all they put was Ted Bundy I broke out
of prison twice yeah carl panzram hold
my beer yeah because this [ __ ]
holy crap this is just like a crazy
crazy [ __ ] story he was kind of like
a terminator yeah he was just like a
terrible but the weird thing about him
though and the reason that we know so
much about him even though it was so
long ago is that he actually wrote an
autobiography like we'll get into that
and his autobiography it's funny because
like it's a [ __ ] crazy like his life
was [ __ ] crazy like all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that happened and but the thing
about it is that pretty much everything
he's said in there as far as I know has
been like backed up so he wasn't just
like blowing smoke or like you know like
some serial killers were like inflate
you know how badass they are and
everything that motion you did not do
that he was just like being honest most
serial killers don't scare me at all I
they're mostly were just pathetic they
trap people to trickery
you know just trick you or lie or use a
ruse and then they're usually they're
usually messing with a victim that's a
lot weaker than them you know they're
not they're not brave or anything you
know Kuklinski was the closest to it he
was a mob hit man you know he he was
pretty brave even though I think he
[ __ ] at about half of that [ __ ] yeah
but the other half he didn't post it was
it was enough yeah this guy here he he
had balls I mean he was brave enough to
seek revenge personal revenge on a damn
ex-president that's what kind of guy he
was
yep broken to a damn ex-presidents house
and stole his gun yeah and then use that
to commit crimes
yes sir people and if anybody crossed
him prison wardens or anything like that
and once he was out of prison because he
was a bunch of little sentences you know
short lots of little short sentences
they just didn't how to deal with this
guy you know he was telling what he was
doing they knew what he was doing it's
just that they couldn't prove it you
know
yeah yes back then he really did not
give a single [ __ ] he'd kill prison
guards he'd go [ __ ] track down
wardens and [ __ ] try to get him and
you know they didn't know actually he
didn't kill a warrant warden that was
his buddy that killed the warden Dan
escape
yeah but they killed guards yeah and
shootouts with the cops and everything
this guy was he was in your face with it
yeah he was he was doing he was very big
and he was like by all accounts and
everyone that knew him and stuff like
that said he was super super scary yeah
you know his photographs he could tell
he's a [ __ ] psycho oh yeah I think
didn't seem to have any interest in
women but he went after men and boys
yeah and like I said he usually just
like raped and killed like for dominance
issued that he would just like take all
their [ __ ] and then just kill him it's
like he just seemed like a very and like
what I was gonna say was that he run an
autobiography and it's like the weird
thing is that it's actually very
articulately written he's actually a
very good writer which is strange
because he wasn't really um very
educated but he seemed to have like a
really like a good handle on why he did
it he didn't have like any kind of
deep-seated reasons or anything like
that he was basically just hated
everyone in the human race because he
had been treated like [ __ ] and so he
just thought well I'm just gonna take
revenge on everybody cuz you're all
culpable I got a reason I have a theory
of what happened to him you know he went
through a lot of really bad corrupt
institutions he did a little kid you
know and his parents were I think his
parents were priced [ __ ] bags and they
just had they just gave birth to him and
his family just to use him as workers
really more anything else but I I think
he could all trace it back to a near
operation that he had there's a chance
they said that they mentioned that there
was a botched your operation did you
know yeah they removed something like
from his from his brain it was a mastoid
or something like that um I believe they
did it in the house yeah and they messed
it up yeah and then so later he had to
go to the hospital and like get it
redone or whatever cuz I guess they
didn't get it all over they screwed it
up somehow
they left that I think that was the
beginning I think it destroyed some kind
of center in his brain it might have
that made him very fixated and it kind
of enhanced his rage factor yeah you
know because that is definitely
something that comes up in a lot of
serial killers backgrounds he's kind of
weird brain in a butte brain injury
abuse which he definitely had a lot of
not so much some of it in the family
mostly from his brothers rather than his
parents because his father took off but
mostly like after he started committing
petty crimes and getting put into like
institutions and then he got like
horribly I become what I remember from
what I remember on the in the timeline
though the first thing that happened
happened after that but after that yeah
operations I'm not sure how old he was
when that happens a kid I played a young
yeah I think he was pretty anime became
uncontrollable you know and he was
[ __ ] drinking and doing crazy [ __ ]
like eight after that yeah and that's
how he got put away yeah and then when
that old in that old place they put him
at we talked it we had that we talked
about that place on another show it was
like notorious the damp a pedophiles had
taken over the damn that whole
institution they were raping all those
boys yeah wasn't it that same one I'm
not sure actually it might have been I
think I think we mentioned or it was
like really common and it was a killer
body were actually killing boys in there
yeah the silence um remember they had a
that might have been cropsy though us
wasn't it that might have been yeah that
made no prob you should wear that one
that we were like I think it was kind of
common you know people think that bad
[ __ ] is recent no it's bucks a lot
better than it was well like I said this
guy told her to get it it's harder to
get away with [ __ ] nowadays holy [ __ ]
and institutions do they can't get away
with this [ __ ] they used to be able to
get him know and you know and like I
said I'm not excusing anything he did
because he was a [ __ ] horrible person
yeah but and I'm not saying that he
wouldn't have been a criminal anyway
like even if all of that
Emami but I definitely do think that how
he was treated had a great deal to do
with how he turned out people that
people said that he would reciprocate if
you were nice to him he was nice back to
you yeah but that only happened like a
couple
James which will kind of get into later
on which one of one of those times like
ended up resulting in him writing the
autobiography like I said which is
actually really interesting and really
well-written so let's go through the
timeline and start talking about carl
panzram so as you mentioned earlier he
was actually born in 1891 in the summer
on a farm in northern Minnesota now his
parents were Prussian immigrants and
they had a farm I guess it's like they
called it a dirt farm because it's one
of those farms where it's like a shitty
piece of land and you can only like get
much of anything out of it now he
eventually ended up having five brothers
and one sister I think like at different
sources say he had different numbers of
siblings but yeah so five brothers and
one sister and they all obviously worked
on the farm like farm families did back
then now he has been quoted as saying um
I have been a human animal ever since I
was born
I was a thief and a liar the older I got
the meaner I got now he said that his
siblings were normal but that the traits
that they got that they were like kind
of hard-working farmers and like went on
to have normal completely normal lives
he said he didn't get that gene that's
kind of what he said like not in those
words but yeah so when he was 7 years
old as I said I think before this not
too long before this er right around
this time was when he had the mastoid
remove from his brain which some people
have speculated may have messed
something up in there because like I
said brain injury is very very common in
serial killers head injuries very common
in serial killers when they're young and
it does appear that he had that happen
to him is that fuck-you development up
yeah particularly that age because your
brain is still plastic it's still
growing and you know making new forming
new you know connections and stuff so
yeah that would mess up your raging out
then the connections that your Foreman
or a [ __ ] up - yep so I think that's
what happened to him yeah might have
been and he may have not have been a
greatest [ __ ] genetic stock to begin
with yeah I mean they were they were a
very poor family they were very kind of
Stern not very loving you know what
that wasn't really a thing back then I
remember it was something long lines
where he not only did he work at that
farm full-time he also went to school
every day for eight hours a day yeah
only it was a long time he only ended
get healing and getting like three hours
of two to three four hours of sleep a
day yeah because he went to school for a
really long time and then as soon as he
came home he had to work on the farm all
the kids and to a little kid that might
especially one that was a damaged brain
that might really [ __ ] you up yeah a
sleep deprivation being in the army I
knew all about sleep deprivation sleep
deprivation will drive you [ __ ] crazy
and it doesn't it doesn't take very long
you know and you do kind of adapt to it
yes I think he thought being a sleep
deprived might have been normal yeah so
so sleep deprivation was here it was
like a normal part of your upbringing
who knows what kind of damn psychology
you would develop you know yeah
especially you're not young you're young
you got brain damage and you're being
sleep-deprived
yeah who knows what kind of personality
develops that early and you have other
issues too it's like you don't you're
poor and slow you know you don't you
don't really have like any like family
support or anything like that really
you'd be another you'd be like in an
altered state of consciousness from day
one yeah yeah I mean it's interesting
that all his siblings apparently turned
out okay even though they had the same
upbringing but I definitely do think
that maybe something happening to his
brain there that hadn't language that
kind of nudged him like in the other
direction it goes like I said you know
I'd be the icing on the cake to have
that brain injury yep definitely yeah
but so about seven years old his father
left they didn't you know they were poor
they were immigrants they didn't have
like divorce nobody like hired lawyers
or anything like that the dad just took
off so obviously after that you know
they were down a man so you know the
farm started doing worse and worse the
kids had to you know take it more work
and everything like that you know they
didn't like I said it was a shitty piece
of land that they were farming and they
weren't really growing anything so it
that kind of got shitty also Carl also
said that during this time period
his brothers like to like beat him up
because I guess he was the smallest or
the youngest or whatever um
so he kind of started to learn from an
early age that everyone thought it was
okay to just like beat the [ __ ] out of
him for whatever like even if he just
like did some minor infraction it's
almost good it's almost kind of like he
got used to it at a very early age it's
like well you know they're just gonna
beat the [ __ ] out of me whatever and so
he didn't really you know what I mean so
that was kind of like all he knew he was
actually as you said his first official
arrest was eight years old and it was
for drunken disorderly yeah so he
started early uh-huh when he was 11 he
broke into a neighbor's house and stole
a bunch of stuff including a handgun his
brother has apparently found out about
this and beat the [ __ ] out of him
he also got arrested for that crime and
in 1903 he went to a reform school the
Minnesota State training school in Red
Wing
yes Oda yeah this place is really
[ __ ] about yeah this you know like I
said he might have been like if he
hadn't gone to this place and you know I
I've listened to a lot of documentaries
about this and they're still you know
obviously there's no way of knowing
because he's dead now and this was a
long time ago but it's like some people
are wondering if someone would have
intervened at some point like before he
went to the reform school say like would
he have ended up he was gonna be other
like what I think so too
I think he probably just was gonna be
like but maybe it would have just been
like minor instead of the monster that
he yeah yeah it goes to this place and
it's not a school no oh yeah prison it's
a prison for kids for kids yeah and
there's all kinds of bad [ __ ] the adults
are raping the kids the kids are raping
the kids it's just you know it's bad
yeah it's bad this is what is this 18
something or 18 something 1903 yeah I
mean at that time they didn't really I
mean this is the very early 20th century
they didn't really have any laws like
they have now about you know or they
didn't have anybody like looking into
yeah what anyone was doing institution
or easy to corrupt back there well yeah
so it's like basically all of these
little prisons and reform schools is
like they kind of turned into people's
like personal fiefdoms yeah
you could pretty much just get away with
anything well that [ __ ] kind of went on
especially in places like England all
the way up you know into the [ __ ] 60s
yeah with them you know special schools
and I mean like it boarding school where
they would paddle kids and beat them and
you know and it hit him on the ass and a
head you know like different [ __ ]
tools for different levels of offenses
and [ __ ] nowadays it lock people up for
that yeah but back in the days you know
I mean that's what I mean that's why
corporal punishment I do not think the
good old days were yeah you know and the
people who were administering it were
like getting into getting off on it mmm
probably were they seem to think and I
don't know if they really thought this
or if they just like were sadists and
just enjoyed beating the [ __ ] out of
people but they seem to think that that
was the only way that you could correct
bad behavior which is by beating it out
of that it was something that was handed
down probably going back hundreds of
years which doesn't work the kind of
person that would be attracted to that
job is the kind of person that would
want to make is that a little the kids
so exact know what kind of person that's
gonna [ __ ] attract yep come on
yep and that's exactly what ends up
happening there's a clue it ends up
happening it's just like a horrible
vicious cycle like I said you know
people [ __ ] about now but it's like a
[ __ ] million times better than it was
back in the early 20th century I mean
they didn't even there were no laws to
protect you from this kinda not really
it's like they weren't really enforced
if there were it's like you know I mean
no one really thought anything of it
there's like oh the kids are bats just
beat the [ __ ] out of them and yeah
that's the only way that to get through
to them that's kind of what they thought
yeah you can rape them and then again
but yeah that didn't happen yeah it's
like they wouldn't even like nobody even
talked about they wouldn't believe you
yeah are you just a like kid yeah it's
[ __ ] up yeah they didn't really
especially for kids you know and it's
like well you did if they believe them
they don't think they gave a [ __ ] no I
do I really don't think they did
a lot of that had to do with what your
station in life was yeah yeah man if you
were if you were a [ __ ] delinquent
even you know even here in the United
States you know that you know which
nowadays you're look at the United
States like well you know Scotland
rights here not really not back in those
days now if you were manure from a from
a good family
you were [ __ ] yep basically and you
could just people could just do
they wanted to you because you buck me
and it seems kinda yeah seems like so
yeah this administered thing miners had
any rights I don't think they did it not
not the way we understand that is to do
with the problem yeah because I feel
like particularly you know Victoria
Naren a little bit afterward I feel like
they almost treated kids not like kids
like that they just kind of treated them
as like you know you know they're all
out working on farms it's like they're
treating them like you know putting
going down the coal mines and [ __ ] like
yeah they were like adults when they
need me right right so does that count
kind of like slaves yeah that's pretty
much exactly it was like and like I said
you could just beat the [ __ ] out of them
if they weren't yeah you know and and
then they would wonder like why these
kids would burn miles and stuff like
that I'm like because that's all you're
teaching that is you're just like
beating the crap out of it yeah you know
and that kind of shit's going on in the
cities on the East Coast and then you
wonder why the Wild West was wild yeah
cuz those kids were all coming out of
that environment and going I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know go look for gold out in
the dab you know hills or yeah I'm gonna
go get my own plot of land I'm gonna
fight off some of these Indians and make
my own house that kind of [ __ ] yeah
Jeremiah Johnson type [ __ ] also known as
liver-eating Johnson he was the American
Conad I love that livery Johnson yeah
that [ __ ] killed another
[ __ ] with another [ __ ]
yeah he escaped from the Indians killed
an Indian dude cut his leg off and then
use the leg to beat beat another Indian
to death and then walked 200 miles or
300 miles home in the in the winter non
on that Indians leg for sustenance
didn't we talk about him on like one of
the other shows I feel like we did
because I remember that sorry delivery I
was like he was what like walking
through the wilderness like like you
know like one of those big old turkey
legs it did yeah that's right he was in
a once [ __ ] he was a in a one-man war
against the crow Indians cuz they killed
his his wife who was a Flathead Indian
yeah so you know evidently fought him
until he was mad he became a legend
among the crowd he got old and they
would worship him as a badass he made
peace with him eventually
like well you ate all our livers well
their brain Johnson
you're all right yeah yeah so this this
particular training school quote-unquote
was actually like a kid prison at the
time that carl panzram first went there
he there were about 300 other boys there
aged between about 10 and 20 and like I
said there was no oversight there was no
anything so it's like the jailers and
everything could do pretty much whatever
they wanted to the boys and they did
panzram was they said that his crime
when he was first like checked into the
school was incorrigibility he also said
in his later autobiography that as soon
as he got into the reception office that
one of the staff members stripped him
naked and questioned him about his
sexual practices and this is a quote
from his autobiography he says he
examined my penis and my rectum asking
me if I have it if I had ever committed
fornication or sodomy or had ever had
sodomy committed on me or if I had ever
masturbated yeah
it's already scouting him out yeah so
this is the kind of environment right I
mean I don't you know yeah carl panzram
he's a monster and everything like that
but I really don't have any reason to
doubt anything that he said about know
that [ __ ] happened they did happen
because I've heard it for other people
as well that they said at that place
that he was talking about was notorious
yeah that kind of that kind of [ __ ] yeah
now this place was also run pretty much
Lee was under Christian fundamentalism
so you basically if you [ __ ] up one
thing like if you did it even if you
didn't like do your lessons right then
they would just like beat the [ __ ] out
of you so Carl kind of got beat up a lot
because he had grown up on a farm and he
didn't really he could read but not very
well so every time he messed something
up like when he was trying to read or
something like that they would beat the
crap out of him and [ __ ] like that
so him being treated in this way gave
him a lifelong hatred of religion he
attributes this to like his time at this
school he says this was the beginnings
of degeneracy and he said this is also
where he learned to lie and learn to be
a hypocrite you know
I mean so when like I said when he's
like kind of writing later on about you
know the the beginnings of his you know
criminal career or whatever he says I
first began to think that I was being
unjustly imposed upon then I began to
hate those who abuse me then I began to
think that I would have my revenge just
as soon and as often as I could injure
someone else anyone at all would do so
he had already got to the point
apparently as a young kid that I hate
everybody and everyone is responsible
for me being treated this way so I and
I'm just gonna like hurt as many people
as I can hurt because of how he was
treated yeah he becomes a rage monster
he just hated the world because he did
live in a [ __ ] in a hell it was yeah
if you actually once you follow this
guy's life it was one prison one hellish
prison after the other being with
hellish guys this guy was a demon yeah
he's a demon and he [ __ ] just hated
life
hey yeah he hated everything and
everybody and he even said he said I
hated everybody and myself yeah so he
just like had no yeah eventually he gets
he gets hung and as he was going to the
gallows
oh don't spoil it what one of the
headlines said one of the newspaper
headlines that are that I read said goes
to the gallows pole cursing his race and
himself yeah yeah pretty much yeah he
just like I said hey everybody just
hated everybody he was like the most
misanthropic person I've ever and that's
saying something for a serial killer you
know everything so um yeah so he's just
getting beaten all the time and like I
said they the [ __ ] they did they had
like you know big wooden planks they had
like the big straps and like big [ __ ]
bull whips and [ __ ] like that so he's
doing all that so he just gets angrier
and angrier and angrier so finally it
builds up to a point where in July of
1905 he built a little device that he
left in the workshop at the school and
burned the [ __ ] thing to the grill
and so this was another something that
he would do he really loved setting [ __ ]
on fire yeah specially churches because
like I said because of this whole
Christian indoctrination thing that they
went through at this school like he
pretty much hated all he hated the
Christian religion and he would go
around and it was the Christian religion
that they had there it was perverts yes
it was just a bunch of damn it would
drive you crazy think of how crazy that
would be yeah they're making you [ __ ]
praying does religious [ __ ] but then
they're also raping you yeah yeah well
in point out they were all hypocrites
yeah he did point out the so you can see
how having these experiences yeah
totally destroy your moral compass yeah
that was [ __ ] was just you the needle on
your moral compass just wouldn't be
there yeah it would be and that seems
like exactly yeah what happened yeah so
yeah so he burned down the workshop at
the school then after a while like he
started listening to other boys that
said you know like if you ever want to
get out of here you just have to like go
along with what they say and just like
pretend that you're like reformed and
[ __ ] like that's how you get out cuz
otherwise you'll just be stuck in here
so um he eventually started doing that
he was like oh yeah you know Jesus loves
me I'm healed blah blah this other kind
of crap um he later said like I have a
lot of quotes like from his book cuz he
he's really um because his writing is
really interesting and like I said he he
has a lot of insight into why he ended
up the way he did but yeah so he said he
pretended to be reformed and then he
said I was reformed alright I had been
taught by Christians how to be a
hypocrite and I had learned more about
stealing lying hating burning and
killing I had learned that a boy's penis
could be used for something besides to
urinate with and that a rectum could be
used for other purposes yeah I think
they also gave him for circumcision when
he was there I don't know if that was
there it might have been a little bit
later I think that did happen but I
can't remember like where in the time
line it happened because I remember he
remember hearing a comment he made about
it says that you know if you can cut the
hands off of you can cut the hands off a
[ __ ] Mozart and he just learned how
to play with his [ __ ] oh yeah
Beethoven he said Beethoven
with his feet or something like that
yeah he did say something like that
didn't he I don't have that quote
written down but I remember like I
remember reading that I said it didn't
stop him no stop him from anything well
I think after that happened to him I
think he was a little bit older when
that happened and I think that he was
just like or no actually I think later
on he had a testicle removed and they
said the first thing like when they put
him back in the prison population or
whatever he want to go rape somebody to
see if the [ __ ] still worked damn so
yeah yeah so um yeah so 1905 in the
winter Karl's mom comes to Redwing to
pick him up and take him home now the
problem was it's like she had a lot of
[ __ ] going on I mean she had a bunch of
other kids it's like the farm was
failing and [ __ ] like that one of the
other sons had actually died
accidentally he had drowned so she was
kind of going through a lot of grief for
that so she didn't really have a lot of
time to deal with Carl's [ __ ] you know
what I mean she's like he's just a
troubled kid you know he's still a kid
at this stage so he's like you know
maybe he'll grow out of it or whatever
so she wasn't you know as attentive to
him as probably she should have been
like I can't blame her because she had a
bunch of other [ __ ] guy went on to and
her life probably wasn't the best either
but um
Carl said that he actually when he was
young that he had actually quite liked
his mother and had a lot of respect for
her but like as he got older like he
eventually began to hate her you know as
a lot of phone you know killers do
because and of seeing the mother is like
weak that they can't stop what's
happening that type of deal I do think
there's like there save them yeah
there's like a definite because I do
feel like like little kids you kind of
like look to your mom and dad like you
think they they're grown up so they're
gonna like gonna solve all your problems
you yeah and you know if something's the
matter they're supposed to fix it but if
something is the matter with you that
they can't fix then I can see how a
certain type of person might develop
some resentment for that because like
you know why didn't you do anything why
didn't you stop me stop me you're right
why why is that do
you know why you still with that dude
he's the one that's [ __ ] me over
which caused me to do this that type of
[ __ ] yeah yeah so yeah I definitely do
think that but yeah he said that he did
like his mom when he was a kid but then
later he kind of like had a lot of
resentment for her so uh January 1906 he
was about 14 years old at this time so
he is back at the farm you know working
on the farm and everything and it's like
basically he came to a point was like
look there's like no future in this you
know poverty they're just like working
this farm they're not getting anywhere
with it they're still dirt poor so he
talked his mom into sending him
somewhere else like to another school I
don't know this might have been another
religious school I'm not entirely sure
but so he goes to this other school he's
there for not very long and again there
is a teacher there who he you know
starts to come in conflict with because
this teacher has beat him with a whip on
several occasions for him you know not
doing something right or misbehaving or
whatever at this point mmm Karl gets a
handgun which apparently he is stolen
from a neighbor I remember that and he
brings it to school and is planning to
shoot the teacher in the face in front
of the whole class he pulls out of his
pocket and but he fumbles it well what
yeah cuz he starts fighting with the
teacher like the teacher kind of jumps
on him and they're like fumbling and it
falls out of his pants and he got thrown
out of school yeah I think the teacher
kicked it away or grabbed it or
something got it got it in time and he
runs yes he goes on the run you never
goes back yeah he actually he got thrown
out of school at this point and then he
went back to the farm but only for two
weeks two weeks after that he actually
just hopped a freight train and left
okay I thought he went on the run and he
was only 14 years old not this he gets
up on a train man and then [ __ ]
railroad Bub's mr. gang raping him yeah
yeah and he [ __ ] goes to the railroad
police and reports it they don't do
anything yeah just like I said this was
just yeah it's the world that's the way
the world was back then people [ __ ]
don't get it man [ __ ] like I said it's
way better now yeah
if you were poor if you were at the
bottom of society you're especially if
you were in kind of a kind of a bad area
you were getting [ __ ] over probably
yeah it was real hard to enforce laws on
people yeah there was just I mean you
had to think - this was no DNA evidence
no yeah there was an army was not a
litigious society police were kind of a
new thing yeah they had police but they
were kind of like mall cops
yeah like that they really didn't have
an investigative power now if you were
rich you know what I mean he turned up
dead they do an investigation well of
course that a guy like this because
that's an important person yeah yeah
they didn't have city didn't have
manpower yeah yeah I mean even to this
day American cities are staffed
basically glod bias basically by a
skeleton crew of cops yeah I mean you
know you ever involved a Katrina you'd
see that you know the cops said that
storms coming we're not able to hold it
[ __ ] it we're out here they ran the cops
ran from yemm's because it's on a
skeleton crew they ran back to their
wives
oh yes family Susie didn't want to hang
her hound and they evacuated in those
damn cop cars and rent and drove them
across a dam city across the state lines
and [ __ ] abandoned them quit this
full quit the force that's what happened
a lot of them yeah they didn't all do
that an OPD New Orleans Police
Department yeah you know I was there
during that time was a Baton Rouge
knowledge I know all the details but
yeah so you couldn't yeah you couldn't
depend on society back then there to
protect you had to protect yourself and
if you were a young guy like Carl trying
to live on railroads you were [ __ ]
vulnerable yeah and they weren't gonna
lock up a bunch of bums because some
kids said that they raped him he
couldn't prove it yeah they just laugh
you they did laugh it off yeah no one
would do anything about now so so he
spends the next couple of years going
around the Midwest you know basically
sleeping rough going from place to place
um when trains
they had like railroad cops but in a lot
of ways they were like they were a lot
more dangerous than criminals you know
so this was kind of like I mean this
part of the you know in the United
States and in this era it was kind of
like there was like a you know very
large cultural shifts and there was like
all these there was like a whole culture
of like hobos yeah that just kind of
went around the rail they would like
look for work you know various places
around the country when I was a little
kid there was a whole restaurant based
on [ __ ] hobos there that would hobo
Joe's yeah there's a whole culture based
on these [ __ ] yeah and it's funny
because you hear like songs about them
and stuff like that luck almost makes it
sound like romantic like riding the
rails it was a lifestyle I'm like oh
really
it's like I don't really know if like
just riding in a car and getting
gang-raped by a bunch of hobos that
doesn't really add all that romantic to
me and it's like they basically were
just going around begging and stealing
food and living underneath bridges yeah
and like sleeping under bridges is right
behind a salad [ __ ] make money and we
are free we're free man yeah they
thought it was a life of freedom it was
basically I can understand it it was a
lot like I understand it to you like in
a pirate when you think about it yeah
pipe but you don't me not to pay for
anything yeah just trying to live for
free yeah a drink I mean yeah like I
understand like the appeal of that yeah
I'm just saying that in practice it
probably didn't work we're all but out
peace prolly yeah well you had you had
high poverty levels yeah and honest work
pride didn't pay too well so why not try
to eat a free living yeah you know I
mean and have like some adventure
outside yeah because I like you had to
think back then too especially during
the early days of like you know these
guys if they could get work it would
probably like be really really horrible
like hard work like I said be hard work
like in coal mines and [ __ ] like that
and you wouldn't get paid enough for
that [ __ ]
so you can't really blame them for just
being like [ __ ] I'm just gonna ride
around trains just beg food off because
I don't like hippies do you know yeah
dropping out of society yeah [ __ ] like I
said I understand that but yeah so
um so Carl he gets on a train that's
heading out of Montana and came upon
four men who were camping out in a
lumber car they were actually initially
very nice to him they said oh we've got
some clothes or we'll buy some clothes
it's like you can you know sleep in here
with us and ice and warm and stuff like
that oh yeah and you can imagine how
that turned out he was gang-raped by all
four men and he said later on that he
had actually I mean he's a
fourteen-year-old kid he's a
fourteen-year-old kid at this point so
he said and this is the quote I cried
begged and pleaded for mercy pity and
sympathy but nothing I could say or do
could sway that would sway them from
their purpose so at this point he said
this is when he learned that it's like
I'm just gonna [ __ ] everybody over
because otherwise they're gonna [ __ ] me
over first because and he was like you
couldn't trust anyone because they
pretend to be nice to you and they're
don't you ever so they didn't kill him
but he did actually cut he did get away
now later on he got locked up in Butte
Montana this was on a burglary charge
and he got a one-year sentence in the
Montana State reform school this was in
Miles City now he got to this
institution I know somebody wants to
make JA joke about bum bum bum violence
that's right now jokes about this is
like bum ba-bum sexual violence yes I
was going on there man bum we would have
thought who would have thought bombs
Rock up over each other it's [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] crazy man but look you
know and you're a little boy basically
like I said a fourteen-year-old boy and
riding the rails and [ __ ] like that and
it's like I guess he was still fairly
naive yeah at this you know even though
he's been in it it's tough you you think
yeah you think he would know better but
well but he well he said this is like
the thing that basically just made us
like [ __ ] everybody because it's like
they you know they they said they were
being nice to me and they were gonna
give me clothes and stuff like that
right yeah
so but not for free right well yeah
that's essentially what they said
so he gets to the Montana State reform
school he's 14 years old but he looks
like a grown man pretty much he's like
pretty tall he's like 180 pounds now
they kind of recognized the staff at
this reform school apparently recognized
right away that this was like what they
would call a born criminal like this is
someone that is not going to be able to
be reformed like they recognize that as
soon as he came in there so so he got um
a lot of harsh treatment here as well
because they perceived him as
incorrigible so there was one guard
there in particular who kind of made it
his mission to just make Carl's time
here as like as bad as it could possibly
be because I guess he just hated him and
you know he like I said they didn't
think he was going to be able to be
reformed now Carl later said he kept on
nagging at me until finally I decided to
murder him so Carl finds his big ol wood
plank outside one of the workshops and
one night when the guard turned his back
toward him he whacked him in the back of
the [ __ ] head with it now he didn't
die the guy didn't die you know he was
hurt pretty bad but it didn't kill him
so um then Carl said for this I got
several beatings and was locked up and
watched closer than ever before now he
decides at this point it's like this
[ __ ] sucks I'm gonna bust out of this
[ __ ] joint so he was in there for a
little bit longer but it does in 1907
him and another guy that were saying
their name Jimmy Benson they actually
managed to escape from this reform
school reform school their president
cheated prison his child
prisons yeah so these two guys they the
two kids managed to escape they go to a
nearby town they managed to steal
several handguns and then start heading
toward of the town of Terry now it seems
like a right around this time now he
didn't kill Jimmy Benson apparently him
and Jimmy were buddies and they wandered
around together for like a month one of
their favorite things to do
was
setting fire to churches yes Simon
Church is a cinema yeah and they would
rob them first and then burn them down
no Sun clear when they say robbing
churches they mean burglarizing the
churches are robbing everybody in there
by gunpoint
is that what thinking they they probably
burglarized Verizon has then broken when
it was closed when no one was in there
at all took a bunch of [ __ ] and yeah
because I mean if they set it on fire
with people in their youth
oh gee black metal action yeah and it's
funny lad pot last podcast the left so
that's like a good Norwegian black metal
bands like gonna react this seemed like
um like og [ __ ] yeah this seemed like
one of carl panzram favorite things well
he didn't like he didn't like religion
thought he did not cuz you know from his
point of view that [ __ ] was hypocritical
as hell mostly I meant rape yeah men but
sex yeah yeah well you're talking about
how [ __ ] holy how holy you are the
but yeah so yeah yeah so evidently they
say that [ __ ] Catholic Church is just
like it eaten up with it right now man
right now I think it always has always
been he eaten that with at the top not
so much at the bottom but at the top
yeah yeah yeah I'm one of them I think
one of the one of the deputies the guy
wrote right underneath the Pope is like
under investigation for like trafficking
of like trafficking like kids in in the
hundreds yeah maybe it might been
thousand I've been drinking of course
you don't I mean numbers kind of yeah
there's in the millions yeah millions
and tens of millions here yeah but yeah
so uh yet burning down churches was
pretty much his favorite thing one of
the I guess kind of [ __ ] up but sort
of funny things he says later was that
naturally I now love Jesus very much I
love him so damn much that I would like
to crucify him all over again yeah this
guy said some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but it is
like I said he leaves out all them hate
it's kind of funny in a fucked-up way
like that's why I'm using a lot of
quotes from and stuff like that and like
I said that's what I was saying like
don't spoil like when they hanged him
and stuff cuz like this well they
shouldn't know this [ __ ] he said like
right before they hang in there what
they said about it was it was pretty
good too yeah but you know cursing his
race and him
yeah I'd like to hear what he said about
his race white [ __ ]
maybe you just meant like the human race
I think it was just a cursing his race
yeah yeah and himself yeah although I
actually you know I'm gonna say right
now I what the dude went through I
really don't blame him for having them
out of hatred that he had no sorry
that's what I mean you can't really yeah
I can't [ __ ] I can't [ __ ] go along
with him [ __ ] raping and killing
killing innocent boys what she did what
she did far as I know they were innocent
yeah yeah I don't know if they made him
mad or what well some of them I don't
even think he said they made him buddy
yeah they just wandered by and he just
plucked out him right so so yeah there's
no excuses oh he didn't he thought he
saw everyone else is a monster himself
so himself as a monster and everybody
else's monsters because nobody was that
everybody was bad to him see he just
said [ __ ] got everybody yeah he
became a human atom bomb just yeah kill
everything that the crime writer Harold
Schechter I think he called him a
one-man apocalypse yeah yeah kind of
like a really I look at guys like places
bait I look at guys like this as a
natural disaster that yes that's a good
way of putting it yeah
it's they're not fully responsible they
were they were created yeah is actually
responsible you know but yeah I mean
there's no thing to do that but I can
understand why they started to Connor go
in that direction just that the hatred
was all-consuming yeah you know I mean
it's like a modified form of suicide
they're gonna kill themselves but
they're gonna take other people will
yeah that's exactly what it was like
yeah well yeah so um so Karl and Jimmy
like they traveled around for about a
month together like burning down
churches you know breaking into houses
robbing people and whatever so they
ended up with like a couple of guns they
had like a few hundred dollars like back
then which is quite a bit of money
finally they got to Fargo and decided
they were gonna you know go their
separate ways so they did at this point
carl panzram changed his name to
jefferson Baldwin and
he ended up back in North Dakota and
then in December of 1907 he shows up in
Helena Montana which at that time was
still a very kind of Old West deed there
wasn't a lot of cops you know
everybody's still walked around with
pistols on their belts and stuff like
that mostly it was like fur traders and
fishermen and stuff like this it was a
bunch of like hard-ass type of dudes you
know so Carla kind of fit right in now
apparently um like I said he's still a
teenager at this point so he's in a bar
one night and he's kind of drunk and he
there's I guess I've recruited an army
recruiter Mike came into the bar and
started like given his like spiel about
joining the army and um for some reason
Carl was like yeah that sounds like a
good idea so he lied about his age
because at this point he was only 15 or
16 years old and enlisted in the army so
he leaves for boot camp which was at
Fort William at Fort William Henry
Harrison which was in western Montana
so he gets assigned as a private to
Company A in the 6th Infantry the very
first day of boot camp his first date in
the army he was already brought up on
charges of insubordination for refusing
a work detail
the following month he was jailed
several times for various petty offenses
mostly being drunk not following orders
starting fights all that type of stuff
he just had no I don't even know why he
wants military he hated authorities so
much he just seemed like it was like oh
this seems like a good idea at the time
I guess he's probably had a romantic
vision of it maybe yeah yeah you know
fight Indians
that's probably yeah I think I think
that was definitely what he was doing oh
I'll just go it I'll get to go out and
kill people and like you know be like
Mexico yeah
I feel like that's probably what it was
yeah he was in there like a day and he
already saw it from what I remember he
also robbed the place blind just store
and he did well yeah he he pretty much
throughout his whole entire life he
would just steal anything that wasn't
nailed down yeah and he got caught for
it a bunch of times so good apparently
wasn't very good at it but yeah so April
nice
wait just as you said he actually broke
into the quartermaster's building and
stole a bunch of clothes which was about
$90 I guess at the time so then he
started he wanted to go a bath with the
stolen [ __ ] but got arrested by the
military police and threw in the
stockade yeah he was gonna go AWOL and
cash in on his vast vast riches earned
from stolen uniforms yeah that's what
[ __ ] well I think he'd be a little
smarter than that
he doesn't seem like it's weird because
his writing is very articulate but then
a lot of the [ __ ] that he did was really
dumb
sounds like he's he got caught a lot
yeah sounds like he kind of had a little
bit delusions of grandeur about yeah you
could do with certain things although
you know there's different there's
different you know there's different
what I say there's different modes in
his life different you know I mean we're
eventually gonna start getting into the
damn when he was starting [ __ ] with
yachts yeah where he the James Bond boys
that was some weird dude yeah yeah he's
a weird dude yes I think a lot of it had
to do with uh just trying to just trying
to [ __ ] grift and find a good gig and
try to become famous and rich and and
have status I guess yeah cuz it seemed
like all he was doing he would just
drift from place to place and just steal
[ __ ] steal [ __ ] and then he thought he
was gonna get caught so he had to like
run and like you know escape and he had
to like go someplace else and he changed
his name like he went through a whole
bunch of different aliases and [ __ ] like
that
yeah sure yeah like I said it's [ __ ]
trip he had some willpower though but
we'll get done it man
yeah he hasn't really started yeah this
is pretty minor yeah yeah he has this
stage he's a real yes even he hasn't
killed anybody he's a real amateur at
this
this yeah still yeah he gets he gets
more destructive as he goes oh yeah so
yeah so he ends up getting through the
stockade like I said for for thievery he
got a general court-martial in april of
nineteen oh eight where he pleaded
guilty to three counts of larceny now he
got disarmed
dishonorably discharged from the Army
and he was given three years hard labor
so he was actually sent to Leavenworth
the very famous Fort Leavenworth prison
in Kansas now this will come up later
but the guy who approved the prison
sentence was the then Secretary of War
President future president William
Howard Taft now remember that name the
big fat one that got stuck in the best
master big mustache I want you to
remember this name Taft this will come
up again yeah he wasn't president at the
time you know Secretary of War but he
was the one that apparently approved the
sentence the three-year prison sentence
at level yeah pants remembers remembers
this dude later on you'll see ya didn't
forget so yes so he gets panzram gets
thrown into a train inside a cattle car
like with a bunch of other military
prisoners it's a thousand mile trips and
trip and they gave them no food or water
so they end up at Leavenworth um so
let's see what what's the time I guess
it's 51 minutes should we take a break
yeah I take a break all right so we're
gonna take a break right now and I'll
kind of get my [ __ ] back together and do
a bathroom break find a cat you know and
all those other kind of stuff and then
we come back we will talk even more
about carl panzram so we'll be back in
just a few minutes hey sweetheart look
we're Oh
where'd she go okay that's it she
decided to come in the room visit while
you're recording the show yeah she keeps
crampo2 your fleas it feels good
whatever it is look at that eye that's
like when you have a q-tip and stick in
your ear and it like feels really really
good community new one oh she loves her
daddy no tanks huh yeah you gotta watch
cuz she goes on the back porch and
there's ticks out one week about a tick
on her the other day but we got it off
the Hokie
Florida yeah look at that feel pokey you
look like you're shaky I've been
drinking yeah don't eat me man oh yeah
yeah did you see the angry look I know
she's [ __ ] up your camera no no see
that's what sometimes in the camera
shakes that's what she's doing
yes you like why are you doing that come
here or biting it yeah what she might in
a minute
yep yes yes yes she's buying it that's
the that's the [ __ ] assistant get
your move she bites everything she loves
metal thing if it's metal she bites it
yeah look at her chewin must feel good I
guess but it's like I don't I've been
trying to get her to stop doing that
like I got all kind of chew sticks and
stuff but it works temporarily but then
she's like no I think I'm gonna chew on
this instead oh my goodness
whatever alright let's stop filming it
now okay you can go back you can go back
that way now if you want yeah yeah so
yeah I might eat this Jim will eat it
I'm gonna eat it you're so silly
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
okay we're back yeah talking about carl
panzram had to go get pokey shoes to way
down by the pond see I don't like that I
checked if there's no alligators in
there there better not be you swept the
flashlight across it if there's
alligators in the pond little eyes pop
up yeah but yeah so uh talking about
carl panzram now when we last left old
carl he had just arrived at Leavenworth
prison for a 3-year sentence this was
for larceny now this was in May 1908
Carl was at this point only 16 years old
although the guards did not know that so
just treated him just like everyone else
now just like many other prisons of this
period Leavenworth was kind of a
hellhole they you know torture was fine
you know they had a thing where the
inmates all had to be completely quiet
like you weren't allowed to talk like
out of turn unless you were asked a
direct question it was a military and if
you did talk then they whipped you and
threw you in solitary yeah so you know
it wasn't a fun time so panzram started
getting into trouble pretty much
immediately because like I said he just
couldn't help himself he just really had
a problem with authority and he just did
not you know he's just breaking rules
right and left so he got the [ __ ] beat
out of him like pretty much all the time
he actually tried to escape not long
after he got there but failed but so he
decided that he was instead gonna set
another fire so he burned down one of
the prison workshops which caused more
than $100,000 in damage now he never got
charged with this particular crime but
he did get in trouble for a bunch of
other things he also had you know like
in the old Bugs Bunny cartoons and [ __ ]
like that when they show like the
prisoners with like the big ball and
chain yeah he had one of those it was a
50 pound ball yeah and he had to like
carry it all the time
like when he was sleeping and so like
that like it was changing his leg yeah
you'd want him running yeah so he
actually ended up they sent them to the
rock quarry and for ten hours a day
there and break rocks which was kind of
dumb from the prison's point of view
because the longer he was there he's
sitting there like breaking all the
rocks at the pickaxe and Stephanie she's
getting bigger more muscular and
stronger to the point where he he got to
a point where he was like stronger than
like pretty much everybody else in there
yeah
which to me seems a little
counterproductive from a prison guard
maybe a roof no clearly used to be back
in the you know the 70s and 80s they put
weight piles out there and let the
inmates work out until those dudes got
[ __ ] huge it took the head to take
all that [ __ ] away oh yeah that's the
last thing you want is like a bunch of
criminals and it can find locations
they're smuggling steroids in big buff
arms and [ __ ] yeah yeah knocking each
other's heads off so um he actually did
his most of his sentence here he got he
got out in 1910 and even though he said
this is a quote I was a pretty rotten
egg before I went there but when he got
out he said I was the spirit of meanness
personified he said when I left there
all the good that may have been in me
had been kicked and beaten out of me so
he left in the august of nineteen ten
and when he left he just said you know
I'm never coming back to this place
again that would end up not being the
case he would actually end up going back
there later on but um you know so after
he gets out he's 19 years old um you
know he's obviously spent most of his
life at this point in various prisons
and reform schools so you know he didn't
really have anywhere to go
he didn't really have any prospects or
anything like that um so he basically
just decided I'm gonna go around the
country and [ __ ] [ __ ] up Mike and uh
Mike Amanda's yeah like I said he seemed
to [ __ ] [ __ ] up well not like this
Yeah right yeah now apparently he had no
interest in women either hated women or
just didn't wasn't interested in them at
all that's some weird [ __ ] I don't it's
weird
because he doesn't seem like I don't
know it doesn't seem like he's gay it
almost seems like he's asexual yeah in a
weird way yeah I think his sexuality was
just totally weaponized against other
men yeah I don't think he had done
anything do it intimacy or sexual
interest or anything like that no and
during the time that I can based on what
I remembered that he had no female
victims not even mentioned females he
had no interest in them no not at all so
there was no sex drive there I don't
think in this guy yeah it really does
not seem like not in the or on a normal
sex drive no like that's what I mean
when I say he doesn't seem even though
he raped men like all that and boys all
the time I don't think he was gay is
that you would understand say the best
things in life were whisky and sod
whisky and saw to me yeah and I think
he's talking about those little boys but
they weren't really motivating him he
only he only had a handful yeah it's not
like he was a typical you know I mean
pedophile serial killer where he's
[ __ ] gun inform every day yeah it
almost just seemed like a one wandered
by like you take advantage like an
opportunity but it was just cut yeah he
just seemed very opportunistic and like
I said you know the what the men that he
raped it was usually in the course of
robbing them like he would robbing then
he said oh well the bootys here and he's
free so might as well take advantage of
that and then I'm gonna kill him anyway
so it's almost kind of like he was just
taking everything well get from this
person it was kind of one of those
situations where he said he did it for
dominance yeah that's because he had
been raped yeah that way so he's just
like payback yeah it's just like part of
his yeah pain of revenge and it might
you might want to look at it so I'm kind
of like some sort killers will say that
when they look in the victims face they
see their own fears in it yeah it's kind
of like they're conquering their own
fears by making somebody else go through
it yeah it might be a way of becoming
master of rape yeah to where you're not
I mean yeah I've been raped you know but
but I can read you
yeah I'm not scared of it it might be
some [ __ ] like that I think that
probably is
and what it is yeah and you know
probably got to point where dude jump on
his booty and just like [ __ ] like
this so he says [ __ ] it he say he flips
it around his mind like rape defense I
know I'm gonna make all kinds of memes
talking about this rape defense and
that's where he switches on over to
power bottom yeah like yeah go ahead go
ahead do it that do that ain't [ __ ] got
ain't [ __ ] you think you think you you
don't have me yeah you know cuz I'm
gonna get you next yeah go ahead
my turns next yeah it might be that kind
of rationale going on yeah
yeah I mean I mean it basically seems
like his only motivation for anything
was just revenge
yeah cuz soon he when he was getting
raped as a little kid he was probably
thinking how to rape you [ __ ]
back yeah he didn't have the power to do
it yeah he was just a little later on he
had the power to do it so if he can ran
across the guy he wanted to [ __ ] up his
imma I'm gonna get back I'm gonna get
back on you guys yeah I hate you guys
yes he just hates all everybody and I
mean you see it happen a lot with you
know some people that were abused as
children and sometimes they will grow up
to become abusers themselves and that's
it's a similar kind of thing because
when you're getting abused when you're a
kid there's obvious you can't do
anything about it because your abuser is
much larger than you right so when you
get larger you feel like you're gonna
take it out on everybody else like the
way you were treated because it made you
feel powerless so you're getting back at
the world by making them feel powerless
yeah now you're you're mastering your
fears yeah yeah I'm done it's definitely
a [ __ ] up way of yeah the things
dealing with the thing that made you
afraid you're now using that same power
against somebody else yeah so you're
conquering it yep
kind of like the mastery of fire because
everybody knows booty is fire is a thing
I came up with yeah okay I like it I
like it well I it gave me an interesting
it gave me an interesting mental picture
yeah so the following few years Karl is
drifting around Kansas Texas he ends up
in California now during this time
period like I said he hasn't killed
anybody yet
he gets arrested several times during
this time period and he's going by the
name Jeff Baldwin mostly was for arson
robbery vagrancy that type of stuff he
actually ended up he was jailed a couple
of times but did two escapes one was in
Rusk Texas and the other was in the
Dolls I guess it's called the dolls yeah
and that's an organ he also said that he
would amuse himself if he was bored by
just burning [ __ ] down barns churches
he's like it would be a fence I don't
care he's like he would just burned down
anything oh he was also pyro oh yeah big
time
that was one of his favorite things
because along with [ __ ] abuse yes so
yes and a lot of a lot of serial killers
do that as well start fires when there
are kids and are really into fire yeah
whatever reason so another thing that he
would do like I said he burglarized a
lot of houses and whatnot
he always the first thing he looked for
was handguns and so he would steal any
handguns he found and then if he had
money he would always buy bullets and he
said that again when he was bored when
he wasn't setting fires he would go and
buy ammunition for his handguns and then
he would just go around like shooting at
people's houses their cows horses
whatever just shoot a horse like just
for the [ __ ] of it yeah so he was just
so this guy like I said he's just like
this dude wandering around the country
just [ __ ] causing causing chaos
misery and destruction like wherever he
goes and that was just his thing I guess
then the cat comes and knocks over oh
yeah oh no she's loving on the tripod
yeah the tripod loves you back she's
getting in the cone of power I hope she
does it knock it over
yeah she's kidding like trying over
she's like mommy and daddy are doing
you're not paying attention to me we're
the cat's parents I don't know how that
should have well she is she's like a
human baby yeah if you use [ __ ] funny
hilarious she is that's the best kid
I've ever owned she's [ __ ] the Trib
well her yeah her personality is just
like really energy lays on the bed like
a human yeah it's just funny
lays on her back yeah you were like a
little person but yeah alright so yeah
so he's just going around all those
riding the rails and stuff like that
just [ __ ] burning [ __ ] down shooting
[ __ ] raping people robbing people no
bumps yeah and this is another quote
he's like whenever I met one that wasn't
too rusty looking like a man rusty
looking yeah I would make him raise his
hands and drop his pants I wasn't very
particular either
I rode them old and young tall and short
white and black day it made no
difference to me at all except that they
were human beings
damn so he would just like rape whatever
yeah this guy was this [ __ ] amazing
man it's like not amazing in a good way
it's like this guy is just like yeah
that's just why I wanted to do this guy
for a long time because it's like no
showing this guy because he's a [ __ ]
true he's yeah he's [ __ ] nuts so
summer 1911 he has changed his name to
Jefferson Davis yeah yeah leader of the
Confederacy yeah don't know why he
thought anybody well I guess people did
fall for that so he's like going from
town to town robbing people you know
jumping trains and stuff like that
raping people
raping me will be the booty band and in
yeah yes he's a butt pirate Oh big day
he's a pirate so then he ends up in
Fresno California where he gets arrested
for stealing a bicycle so he goes to a
county jail the sentence is six months
but he escapes after 30 days yeah then
he notices [ __ ] up so he jumps on a
freight train like after he escapes the
freight trains go going Northwest now he
had had some he had some guns that he
had stolen earlier and he had like
buried them outside of town so he went
and picked them up and then he got on
this train now he's in a boxcar with two
bums and this is what he said I was
sizing up the youngest and the
best-looking one of the two and figuring
when to pull out my hog leg and heist
him up that's what he said yeah but then
a railroad cop comes into the car and
was like hey what do you [ __ ] hobo is
doing in here or you know something like
that now he was trying to like extort
money out of them he's like
I won't tell anybody you're on the train
if you give me all your [ __ ] well that
was the wrong boxcar to walk into
because Carl pulls out his gun he says I
pulled out my cannon and told him I was
the fellow who went around the world
doing people good so he basically he
took the cops watch and all the money
that he had then he raped the cop at
gunpoint in front of the bums and then
he turned the gun on the bums and made
the bums rape the cop
damn well he watched that's cold-blooded
it's like what the [ __ ] man
this was this was the [ __ ] quote that
he had he said using a little moral
persuasion and much waving around of my
pistol
they also rode mr. Brickman around day
had the brake man - that's what well
that's the con man so yeah [ __ ] moral
persuasion yeah so he kind of had like a
fucked-up sense of humor about all of
this what does BTK have to say we say
about that BTK almost man's totally
control simple it's a very simple way
being a church-going man myself we
understand sodomy is not it's not
approved you know you can't do that you
can't do that Trump you as an officer of
the law that's on it totally
unacceptable something acceptable I
would never do that of course that yeah
yeah Dennis was more Lisa he was had a
good relationship with the police
he's one of them you see he's dog
catcher and you know he spilled his guts
and they work together as a team to [ __ ]
him to expose everything in the case you
know I mean he has a law abiding yeah
that's how Dennis saw himself it was
that's kind of funny about him I still
need to like I I just finished the UM
the Ian Brady book and then and then I
have to start the BTK one but like I
said the whole time I'm reading that I'm
gonna be hearing it in your mobile yeah
yeah it's like you totally
read it out loud oh this [ __ ] won't put
it up there's like a special edition
I'll bring some read some BTK some
Dennis some Dennis right yeah yeah you
have to do it oh yeah man you know
sexual problems thank you
some men have sexual problems yeah this
guy kind of had some well I don't even
know this guy oh this guy sprawling
sexual problems he had like a lot of
other problems though so yes he's just
about power yeah he's just like a Mauer
and vengeance he's like a rabid dog yeah
you know what I mean but and he kind of
knew that which was the weird thing like
he was completely aware of it so he's
traveling around the northwest and was
arrested several times this time using
the pseudonym Jack Alan what's funny you
know for any you listeners who are maybe
like in foreign countries this is all
happening basically in the cowboy days
this is really not remove 1970 tell it
from the [ __ ] late 1800s which is
cowboy times you know from the Wild West
it looks it's it's only a few years
removed from that yeah yeah so this is
like it yeah it's like it's all
imaginers yeah and we have a pirates and
[ __ ] yeah
imagine like [ __ ] Butch Cassidy or so
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you know John Wesley
Hardin coming up pull a gun on you and
just like in blood [ __ ] can you just
think it's funny
yes we explained the origins of the term
yeah I think we think we did but it was
probably like a long time I I caught me
me and Steve and my friend Steve we're
growing my school called the whole Black
Orchid what horking was it basically
meant to get be stabbed but where we got
this from is a video game that we used
to play at 7-eleven sold stand up
cabinet called rat Stan brass Dan was a
[ __ ] Conan knockoff it was a plat is
just like a scrolling platformer where
you just kind of you know let me jumped
over [ __ ] and swung from [ __ ] stuff
monsters you know well
what whenever rest in got killed he fall
in these little pit spikes and the
spikes sometimes it looked like it hit
him in the ass and he would make a sound
and Steve said he got hurt that's what
started it and then we notice we can't
fall in that same pit and this spikes to
get you on the ass you're wearing a
little [ __ ] little little and I said
I'm in the ass yeah and then Steve goes
yeah he's blood worked what worked and
that's that started and that's what yeah
stabbed and something the ass is the
same as sucking raping some an ass
that's called but working yeah being a
[ __ ] too man what he told me that story
because I think this is like a 17 year
old 60s yeah he's like years and years
ago but I think you said I don't even
remember we were talking about was like
you said something about bud work just
like I knew what he meant but I didn't
ever there's a term that was a term me
and Steve made up in our [ __ ] youth
because of it right because of the video
game rats - oh my goodness I just saw I
just thought baby cookie like yawning
over your shoulder yes she's bored with
my stories she's like whatever daddy
but yeah so uh under the name Jack Alan
Carl was arrested several times for
highway robbery assault and sodomy
he was actually put in jail at a place
called The Dalles Oregon he was there
for only a couple of months and then he
busted out so apparently this town was
like kind of a rough place this was like
we're all kind of the Pirates and you
know criminals and outlaws and [ __ ] like
that hung out so he's like running out
of town with this like [ __ ] posse
like going after her whatever so a few
days later he gets arrested again for
stealing so like I said this dude's a
criminal but he doesn't seem like the
brightest criminal because he keeps
getting caught although every time he
gets caught and put in jail like he
usually escapes I guess he's I guess I
got a feeling like you
got a feeling he's one of these guys
actually that kind of like
sadomasochistic a sadomasochistic almost
kind of like Albert Fish yeah
and going to prison is part of his
[ __ ] fetish yeah himself back into
hell he did say something later on that
in prison was the only time that he
didn't feel like an animal yeah which I
thought was a very weird thing to say um
but yeah so he gets arrested again and
he gets thrown into Jesus for stealing
this time and he gets thrown into jail
in Harrison Idaho this time he was using
the alias Jeff Davis now this jail was
um I guess it was a little bit
understaffed and they weren't running it
all that well so the first night he was
there he set another fire in one of the
buildings and during the ensuing melee
him and several other inmates escaped
yeah so yeah so he ended up and pretty
smart yeah it's like dumb but I guess he
just thought I could burn this place
down maybe it's just pure luck cuz he's
a pyro yeah I'm gonna make a fire when I
make a fire yeah and then it burns down
and he goes oh it's like I didn't even
mean for that to happen might be some
[ __ ] like I just started a fire for the
[ __ ] of it you know what I mean yeah so
uh he gets arrested again like after he
took off in Chinook Montana he was being
Jefferson Davis again this time this was
burglary and he got a one-year sentence
at the Montana State Prison at Deer
Lodge now this prison I guess this was
like from the time period in the United
States where they decided for whatever
reason to like build all the prisons to
look like European castles from the
medieval era yeah so that's what this
one looked like so um so he goes to this
prison at Deer Lodge on April in April
of 1913 on the form when he was going in
he listed his occupation as waiter and
teamster okay now at this particular
prison I guess they cuz it's some
prisons you know they
have like work details or you know other
things like to keep the inmates occupied
this one they didn't really have that so
pretty much the dudes were like bored
all the time they were just kind of like
stuck in their cells like they didn't
have a lot of for them to do now when he
was at this particular prison he ended
up running into his old friend Jimmy
Benson who he had traveled around for
for a month like burning churches down
and stuff so Jimmy Benson was also was
doing a twith had a ten year sentence
for robbery so um they kind of got
together said hey bust out of this place
and they had had the plan and everything
like that however right before they
could go through with the plan Jimmy got
transferred so he didn't get to
participate so panzram just at [ __ ]
well I'm just gonna go by myself in so
he did he did escape his so he I guess
he wasn't that dumb because he did like
escape from multiple prisons well I got
a lot of time to think about it price
yeah I guess so so yeah so he escaped
from that prison however he was only out
for about a week but then later he was
in a town called Three Forks and stole
some [ __ ] again and was arrested again
for burglary this time under the name
Jeff Rhodes now he got another year like
put onto a sense for the escape he got
sent back to the state prison where he
was so he says that he was in this
prison for a little while
like I said it was kind of understaffed
they didn't have a lot for the prisoners
to do so a lot of times they just like
hung out in their cells and they were
really bored he said at that place I got
to be an experienced wolf I would start
the morning with sodomy work as hard at
it as I could all as I could all day and
sometimes half the night - he was
[ __ ] everybody
yeah damn so he apparently everybody
because he was kind of a big muscular
dude and was scary as [ __ ] apparently he
found it very easy to like intimidate
the other inmates into giving it up
yep given up that booty you know because
pretty much you know as soon as he came
in he's pretty much like oh right I'm
raping all you [ __ ] and it was
like guarantee you that's why he's gone
to prison it maybe it is yeah
although he didn't really seem to have
problems finding people to rape when he
wasn't in prison but it was easier when
you're in prison because they were all
this way they couldn't guess they
couldn't run away that's [ __ ] yeah I
think he is gay I think he's gay but
he's a leather daddy basically he's a
retro leather daddy before they had a
word for that
yeah yeah just turned him into this
dominant [ __ ] like a Spartan [ __ ]
warrior Spartans used to do that yanking
[ __ ] on the battlefield because
they could well you know they were like
you know next to me you could be never
be a man you know man that seemed you're
a whoa man yeah I definitely feel like
that's what he's doing like Carl had
that kind of mentality as well like I
said that's why it's kind of like you
know it's it's kind of weird to say we
wasn't gay and stuff like that even
though you [ __ ] dudes all the time but
it's like it's if you have any interest
in women like I said it wasn't really
for the same rate he almost seems like
asexual like I said it seemed like he
didn't do it for a sexual interest
really he's a power top yeah yeah he
just enjoyed yeah
dominating the yeah yeah like whether it
was sexually or just beating the [ __ ]
out of them or burning the [ __ ] down or
whatever it's like that has a rock up
okay to get this done and to do that
there's gotta be some there's got to be
some sense some desire that's true
all right you can't will yourself to do
it yeah especially you know on short
notice you know talking about yeah like
I'm in the back of a boxcar with some
[ __ ] stinking bums and you know I
mean I pull a gun on a dude and I just
go
I'm already come hold on wait one second
okay that's you like willing him okay
yeah just jump in like that you know
what I mean [ __ ] no no there's gonna
be I'm not buying that there's gonna be
there's gonna be some [ __ ] ideation
there there's gonna be some [ __ ]
fantasy yeah it's gotta be sexual he's
just not admitting to it yeah maybe it
started it started when he wasn't
[ __ ] real young and all that [ __ ]
happened in that boarding school he
liked it that's what that's what the
deal was yeah probably if not he had
been raping
true yeah I mean he didn't even mention
women he had no interest late yeah
hardly ever yeah so he's lying he's he's
gay he doesn't know how to put it put
that to words yeah you know man yeah his
background doesn't and like I said they
don't really have the same terminology
the term understanding of it yeah we
have now say he doesn't he didn't even
understand it that much yeah probably
not
but yeah so um so even though he had
escaped from this prison at Deer Lodge
but they you know he got caught like a
little while later and they put him back
in there and he actually did end up you
know serving his whole sentence this
time so he gets out in March of 1915 now
he starts like traveling up and down the
Columbia River in the Pacific Northwest
you know mostly in you know trains and
stuff like that now he he broke into a
house in Astoria Oregon in June of 1915
and he stole he stole like some stuff
that wasn't that expensive it was just
like a suit not even think he's stole
any cash or a gun or anything
he stole a watch and then he was trying
to pawn it later and he got caught now
even though this was like a pretty minor
crime and he was under a different name
he was going by Jefferson Baldwin at
this point and like I said this was a
minor charge he gets indicted for
larceny and now the local DA told him
that he was like gonna go easy I'm like
him just like a slap on the wrist or
whatever cuz it wasn't that big a deal
because they didn't know like all the
other should that he'd been up to but
what in it so he said okay well we'll go
in on easy on you to just plead guilty
so he did plead guilty but they gave him
seven years so he like was really really
really understandably like stop about
that because he felt like the DA like
[ __ ] him over because he said if you
plead guilty drinkin yeah you tricked
him so he got a [ __ ] seven-year
sentence for a very very minor it was
like a twenty dollar robbery or
something like that or a burglary so he
goes to the Oregon State Penitentiary in
Salem Oregon in June of 1915
he listed his place of birth as Alabama
which was a lie and also he said that
his occupation was thief yeah that was a
job back then yeah yeah back in Conan
I knew that well he was he was being
truthful about that that was pretty much
how he made his living yeah so again
this was another prison that was kind of
notorious for using torture and like
horrible methods you know even by the
standards of the day I guess it was kind
of notorious the warden at the time was
this guy named Harold or Harry Minto now
he was really over this guy yeah he's
like a big-hearted hard-ass like his
whole thing was like you know you have
to like torture everything out of it was
like whippings he would you put the
water hose it's like they would put you
in isolation for like months at a time
it's like they would do like medieval
torture [ __ ] where they would do like
strappado type stuff like they've kind
of like pull you up off the floor and
like leave you hanging like with just
your toes touching the ground like for
[ __ ] you know they'd leave you up
there for like days at a time like that
yeah they believe in brutal punishment
yeah it's like they would like respect
what I was telling you man they had no
control over the damn institutions fact
ed yeah an institution could [ __ ] do
all kinds of fucked-up [ __ ] to you
yeah like I said there was no oversight
it's like there wasn't really and
everyone I like it's like mental
institutions yeah
mental institutions could do all kinds
of fucked-up [ __ ] - it's so bad that
they closed all the mental institutions
down even though you need mental
institutions
yeah you know you needed a you could
reopen mental institutions in any coup
because there's a means to regulate them
so they didn't become what they were
before what they were before is that if
you just you just didn't like someone
you could stuff him into a damn mentally
well the thing about it - and I think
we'll get into this in a little bit
later - but it's like one of the prisons
that he was in had a mental institution
across from it and it's like the
prisoners would rather stay in the jail
and get tortured then go to the mental
health yeah and nowadays you can you
could make a good mental
institution well it will have to be like
prisons per se they don't have to be
yeah I mean there's like mental like you
know psychiatric facilities and stuff
like that they're just like a normal
hospital or something you can make a
mental institution it's like a town yeah
you know Thurman where there's like
little neighborhoods and stuff in yeah
you know it doesn't have to be like a
hospital that may be kind of a cool
thing to do
yeah cuz then think you could have like
kind of you know you could have like
that you'd have people that have a
normal life but they're under
supervision you know what I mean yeah
and they're not and they're having
treatment is they're having treatment
and they're not [ __ ] they're not
putting the general public at risk
but it's still okay in there yeah you
know what I mean then they're having fun
in there yeah because there's all you I
mean there's no reason to like treat
people with problems that they can't
control like treat them like you can't
bite into my criminals right they're not
criminals they can't help it they're not
it's not on them yeah there's just sick
people so you know what I mean like
they're talking about bringing mental
institutions back in the IOC's and
that's the way a lot of them should be
if you asked me it should just be like
an enclosed community yeah you know I
mean with staff that works I'm gonna
make sure everybody they got jobs in
there yeah yeah I mean and you know
there's gonna be different some people
are so crazy they couldn't be in there
yeah I mean but you know and they go in
there they can even get married I guess
I don't know if need to have kids
because then the kids are growing up in
there so that's kind of difficult I
don't think yeah you ever do that yeah
because you didn't really force the
right kid that didn't that does have any
problems they'll be grown up into
something like that but you know I mean
there's no reason why mental institution
can the [ __ ] that they used to do in
labor supply prisons and mental it's
like they used to torture crazy people
it was like left them like naked in
halls and they were just like covered in
their own filth and like [ __ ] like they
do talk about the little box isn't [ __ ]
what's the [ __ ] did how did they think
that was gonna help anything I don't
think they did think it was gonna do
anything they were just trying to
restrain them I think yeah it's like
they weren't even trying
I like make them better they also
punished them when they had free [ __ ]
that they couldn't control right it's
like that's that's so [ __ ] up and it's
like like I said that's good old days
not good at all you could dump them
uproot you could dump them up a lot and
then just let him let him walk around in
a nice town yeah with the hospital in
there in that town yeah you know I'm
like if they couldn't live in a house
yeah yeah yeah I mean I way this way
that I think they should that seems like
the best like treatment option because
like I said they would have a normal
enough right life and because I think
that that's kind of what the goal should
be yeah you know rather than treating
them like row they're like they're
diseased or something like that like
they used to do that's [ __ ] up man
well they treat them like criminals
actually yeah or they cream like
possessed people too yeah you know they
tried to [ __ ] pray it pray the crazy
away but yeah so they basically they you
know they chained people the walls in
this [ __ ] prison
like I said they hung him from the
rafters for hours at a time or days at a
time they would whip them with
cat-o'-nine-tails like tear their backs
all up and [ __ ] like that so Carl is in
this situation and he later said he said
I swore I would never do that seven
years and I defied the warden and all
his officers to make me and then he said
the warden swore I would do every damn
day or he would kill me right so pretty
much even though he knew that by
breaking the rules he was going to get
tortured and beaten and stuff like that
he just did it anyway like pretty much
every day he was masochistic he would
yeah he would like get in horrible
trouble um so you know he's they're like
a couple of days and already he starts
like [ __ ] [ __ ] up and he got hung up
like hung from a door or something like
that like for ten hours
that was for rising a disturbance in the
cell and cursing an officer then later
he got hoisted up twelve hours for
having like a like a billy club or
something like that yeah and like going
up to another tier of the prison and
like you know [ __ ] he was he was like
trying to incite riots and that kind of
[ __ ] later they found him with a black
jack they threw him in the dungeon for
three weeks with bread and water
so he's like it down there in the dark
naked and [ __ ] like that
he got the hose like a bunch of times he
burned down three buildings
at varying times at this prison he ended
up spending 61 days in solitary and they
gave him hardly no food so he ended up
eating cockroaches yeah so you know
early 1917 he and another inmate named
Otto hooker escaped from the prison now
I don't know because I've heard
different things about it's now Otto
hooker either shot the warden warden
Minto during the breakout or he shot him
later like when he saw him in a town
someplace and was like hey that's that
[ __ ] and then he went up and
shot him I've heard sources say two
different things but hit but hooker did
kill the warden of that prison like
later on now because he had come and
though I kind of feel like you did it's
like some of the people like I said I'm
not I'm not excusing [ __ ] panzram or
any of the people who's like there
everyone's horrible and but if you
nobody involved involved is horrible but
it's like some of the people like that
warden in particular um prime I don't
feel bad that he got killed we can
understand it back in those days what
kind of person was attracted by a job
like hey you know it'd be like some
[ __ ] sadist yeah of course you know
yeah professions attract a certain kind
of person mm-hmm they all did you know
yeah so you got to be kind of suspect
when somebody wants to be one somebody
wants to do that watch it especially
back in those days yeah because
everybody knew like what that [ __ ] was
like back then so yeah that's exactly
who you were gonna get you maybe get
like a hero it was hell and yeah and
you're volunteering to be one of the
demons yeah that's a good way of putting
it yeah so yeah it's like you know so I
don't really feel bad about this
particular guy cuz you know he was
running his prison like that and you
know I think you guys issue yeah so yeah
so he actually so he ended up making
like um I think that he got panzram kind
of got Bri caught and like sent back so
he made a bunch more escape attempts
usually because he was really strong so
he would either try to like you know
pull out like the masonry ender
thing or he would like try to cut
through the bars so he escaped again in
the September eighteenth 1917 he breaks
into a house in this town called tangent
and stole a bunch of stuff including
money food and a loaded 38 caliber
handgun a few days later a local cop
sees Carl running around and recognizes
him because his face was on a wanted
poster this cop tried to arrest him and
Carl pulls out his stolen 38 and opened
fire on the deputy but apparently I
don't think he killed the guy don't know
if he was a rotten shot or what but he
ran out of ammunition and they ended up
catching him now while they were taking
him back to jail he tried to grab the
cops gun and they started fighting
inside the police car the rear windows
at the police car were kicked out and a
bunch of shots went through the roof
panzram got his ass kicked and then he
got brought back to the prison in Salem
and dumped into solitary no like I said
this is why the that YouTube comment
about Ted Bundy I escaped from prison
twice and then Carl says hold my beer
because pretty much every time they put
every [ __ ] time they put her in
prison it's like he just kept skating so
May 12th 1918 he escapes again he sawed
through the bars using a hacksaw blade
and he jumped down off the prison walls
so I think brick broke oh that happened
to live it later okay but yeah but the
the guards were like firing at him
because they were all up in the turrets
and stuff but they missed him like he he
actually made it into the woods yeah
back in these days you can escape from a
prison because there were no computers
yeah you know no man and you could
change your name easily yep so you could
if you could escape if you could get to
another state then you were free yep so
there's a lot of incentive to escape but
you had a he had a hell of a damn
willpower though yeah you do have to it
have a lot of willpower have to admire
his spirit I guess it's like a weird way
of putting it but you know what I mean
did you
see a damn bars on the window I'm gonna
cut through that yeah he was just he was
not gonna be an IE not having tools yeah
you know or brushed through masonry
without any tools yeah I'm gonna find a
tool and then you had to work on it
yep you know yes I can so he was he was
very determined yeah you gotta give him
that you know it takes days to do it
so how do you hide it for those days
yeah that you're working on it I know
it's like [ __ ] yeah Shawshank
Redemption yeah that that poster was big
enough well I don't know down to the
sewage pipe but yeah so see we escaped
into the woods and hopped on a freight
train and headed east he changed his
name to John O'Leary and shaved his
mustache off then he starts heading
toward the East Coast you know robbing
houses burning churches and [ __ ] like
that
now he he ends up in the summer of 1920
he ends up in New Haven Connecticut um
this was kind of like he liked to be in
cities where you know there was a lot of
people because it was it was a lot of
targets you know what I mean like
especially if there was like a lot of
people with money and [ __ ] like that
he also said he liked it because the
cops were probably busy and he could get
away with [ __ ] like maybe without
getting caught so he would go out at
night kind of cruising around looking
for somebody to burgle rape kill
whatever it was so he would like this
was the time of food remember we were
talking about Taft okay so when he's in
new New Haven this is in August of 1920
he sees this house on Whitney Avenue and
he said it looked quote-unquote phat
meaning it looked like somebody with a
lot of money lived there so he's like
well I'm gonna break into that
[ __ ] so he broke in and starts
going through all the rooms he found a
whole bunch of jewelry some like savings
bonds and stuff like that and a 45
caliber caliber automatic handgun then
he noticed that the names from the name
on the savings bond was William H Taft
who at this point like I said he was
Secretary of War early and was the one
that had you know signed the thing like
sending him to Leavenworth in the
interim Taft had been president but he
was not president anymore at this time
he was the former president
yeah so so yeah so he notices like hey
this is [ __ ] tax yeah it's like at
this point attacked was like a I think
he was a law professor at Yale so Carl
like steals all the [ __ ] and then kind
of like leaves the [ __ ] house it take
staffs in 1911 45 pence yep he did so he
goes to the Lower East Side of Manhattan
and steal and sells the bonds and the
jewelry he said he got about three
thousand dollars in cash though he did
keep the gun with the money and he ran
eyes were getting to the yacht with the
money he bought it yacht yeah she called
the akita I'm not sure why he was so
hung up on yachts man but it's like he
really really loved was freedom of
movement I guess yeah there aren't any
cops on the foot on the water true
that's and it's stylish yeah and once
you're out there on the water you could
probably do whatever you wanted to do no
witnesses and stuff oh and he did do
that yeah so yeah I can see what you're
saying
yeah so yeah so he buys a yacht called
the akisto he registers the boat under
John O'Leary which is his alias one of
his aliases and then he goes he sails it
up the East River and uh you know as
he's kind of going up the river he's
stopped so like at other boats and like
you know raids other boats for supplies
you know booze guns pretty much anything
he can find so he eventually moored the
akisto at the New Haven Yacht Club and
kind of hung out there for a little
while you know having a good time so
he's he's raiding the yachts he's
raiding the yachts that were docked yeah
so nobody was in him yeah Yeah right so
he was just kind of going around just
like women are breaking into cars yeah
same kind of thing yeah so when he's
down um in the Lower East Side he
notices that there's like a whole bunch
of sailors there who are on shore leave
because their boats are docked on the
East River so he he thinks to himself
that well maybe a lot of these guys were
like looking for work and here's a like
a whole bunch of victims so what he
started doing was he would you know go
into a bar and he would talk
to him and [ __ ] like that and then he'd
say hey I need like deck hands or
something like that then he would get
them on his boat and then he would get
them drunk rape them and take all their
[ __ ] and then kill them and then dump
their bodies in Long Island Sound so he
did this quite a bit yeah sometimes he
did it with like 10 of them on the boat
at once well that kind of happened later
he usually did one or two at a time
okay um he would like I said he would
just go and he would just go in a bar
and be like hey I'm looking for deck
hands and [ __ ] like that now he did this
like several times but you know the this
was like kind of an era where there was
like a lot of shipping going on there
was a lot of you know boat activity and
a lot of the [ __ ] was going on so it's
like no one really noticed much of
anything amiss you know I mean just
because there were so many sailors and
[ __ ] like that like coming and going so
no one really noticed him like making
off with guys and then them coming back
so yeah so he said he would do this like
every couple of days that he would just
go and pick up you know he'd go around
this bar on South Street in New York and
then he said we would wine and dine and
when they were drunk enough they would
go to bed when they were asleep I would
get my 45 colt ogham
automatic the one that he stolen from
Taft yeah and blow their brains out
damn whatever sleep yeah then he would
tie a rock to the body and you know
thriving Warner story right he raped him
first he probably did I mean you know
what I mean this is Susan this is a
sexual motive yeah this [ __ ] he asked me
yeah he's now he said that at this point
that he killed 10 of them over this like
a few weeks over this time period but it
wasn't all at once it was like or two at
a time okay now after like 10 of them
had disappeared then people started
getting a little bit suspicious that you
know this captain John O'Leary kept
coming into this bar and then like you
know these dudes would never be seen
again so he had actually picked up two
sailors you know at one point and he was
going down the coast of New Jersey when
they got to Long Beach Island
he was gonna kill him but then like a
storm came and they ended up getting
away so like I think like whenever he
crashed a boat yeah the boat like
crashed against the rocks and he had to
swim for the shore and then the other
two guys like swim for the shore too
they I don't think they knew that he was
gonna end up killing them right so um
you know what I mean so they said they
got away now in 1921 Karl ends up
spending six months in a jail in
Bridgeport in Connecticut this was a
burglary and possession of a loaded
handgun then he got he's for a while
like works as a strikebreaker and that
was like pretty much one of the only
legitimate like jobs that he had and he
seemed to like enjoy it because I guess
he could just go right cracking heads
and get paid for it he so he also got
really dry Terron this time period for
being in a gun battle with police so you
know he jumped bail at that point and
fled the state of Connecticut then he
stowed away on a ship and went to Angola
yes on the west coast of Africa Africa
yeah yeah at the time it was a
Portuguese colony right remember that so
he actually gets a job as a foreman on
an oil drilling rig somehow the US
government knew he was there and they
told him I said stay there and we won't
pursue you they knew he was doing [ __ ]
up [ __ ] I think they knew for some about
those uh those sailors he was killed
they suspected that he was involved in
that yeah from what I remember I don't
know I don't know if it really says he
had he had a chance to stay there yeah
but he didn't listen he went back but go
ahead yeah so so yeah he ends up working
for this oil company that was looking
for new sources of oil in this area of
Africa now he's in this town called
Luanda and apparently he's just hanging
out in this town one day and this little
eleven year old boy walks by and he
decides that he's gonna rape and kill
him yeah so he just it was an african
boy it was him so yeah he um basically
the kid walks by he said the kid was
bumming around
that's pretty much all he said like
looking for something or I don't know
but he he like lured him like back into
the you know onto the oil company
grounds and then he raped him and then
killed him by bashing his head in with a
rock yeah and he said his brains were
coming out his ears when I left him and
he will never be any deader diam and
that [ __ ] doesn't allow that your own
kid yeah it was just like walking by
yeah was [ __ ] so it's all that damn
hatred dad did yeah he's like I said he
just hated everything and he didn't give
a [ __ ] he did not give a single [ __ ]
about anyone or anything so then he goes
back to this place called libido Bay on
the Atlantic coast and he started lit he
lived there for it like in a fishing
village for a few weeks the people that
live there seem to suspect that he had
killed that boy but they couldn't really
prove it now a few weeks later he hires
six you know locals to take him into the
jungle to hunt for crocodiles so that's
what he said because apparently at the
time like you know some collectors and
[ __ ] like that would pay a lot of money
like if you had a crocodile so so they
go out on the river and they he
basically just shot them all in the back
he shot him all in the back and then in
the back of the head and then he fed
them to the crocodiles right six dudes
in a boat yeah remember that they scream
guys I think they were yeah Oh laughter
they just like yeah they just lived
around there yeah yeah he just said I
should he said I shot him all in the
back one by one and then I just shot him
in the back of the head make sure they
were doing all the alligators then he
threw him all to the crocodiles that's
some weird [ __ ] had it been more to that
story and then he figured well a bunch
of people saw me when I rented the boat
and when I rented the guys services so I
better get the [ __ ] out of here I bet he
raped him he probably did that one like
I said he didn't really care about white
black and I bet fairly didn't care about
dead or alive either I bet he killed him
and then raped all them while they were
dead then threw him out bet you're some
[ __ ] like that there's there's got to be
some kind of sexual motive at this dude
you know I mean that's kind of going out
of your way just to kill six people yeah
like I wasn't any they didn't have any
money
so there had to be some kind of sexual
motive there yeah he just didn't he just
he pried one of these guys that for some
reason serial killers are not real
[ __ ] they're not real ready to admit
to necrophilia yeah we were talking
about some common on with them like we
were talking about that with Garrett
with Gary I killed this hot kid I can
did you have six and after they did oh
no huh yeah it's almost like they'll
admit to like everything about that but
they were having sex with him one day we
did like Bundy is the same kind of thing
like he admitted all kind of [ __ ] but
it's like yeah he wouldn't really say
that he'd [ __ ] the dead bodies even
though he did I bet you he I bet she had
sex with all six of them dudes up they
were dead it wouldn't shock me to be
honest unless someone fell in the damn
water
there has to been a motive there yeah
and what the guy like this is the boat
of psychosexual what I'm saying yeah
he's just not admitting to it yeah so
after this like I said he was afraid he
would get recognized because a lot of
people had seen him rent the boat so he
starts going up the Congo River and he
ends up at this place called Point
banana and then he eventually ended up
going to the Gold Coast now there was a
local village there and he was like
robbing farmers and stuff he eventually
ended up getting enough money that he
bought passage on a shift to the Canary
Islands but once he got there he
couldn't really find anybody worth
robbing so he stowed away on a ship
which was going to Lisbon Portugal
however when he got there he found out
that the local government in Lisbon knew
about the murders in Africa like and do
what he had done and were like on the
lookout for him he was like you know
public enemy number one or something
like that so they actually had some good
communication going on even back in the
early 20th century so they knew to look
out for him so when he got there and
found out that he was kind of like you
know a marked man he ended up stowing
away on another ship that was going back
to the US so he ended up back in the US
in the summer of 1922 now at this point
he decided that he thought that he would
make a really good hit man which she
probably would so
he decided that that's what he was gonna
do so um so he gets the gun that he had
brought back from Africa and he goes to
this one place and gets it fitted with a
silencer but then when he test-fired it
he was upset because the silencer I
guess didn't make it completely silent
it wasn't quiet enough yes something I
might tell the audience yeah silencer is
not really the correct term it's always
suppressor yeah it is a very misleading
yeah term this whole idea of making [ __ ]
silent through firearms is a Hollywood
invention and it's people still believe
it today yeah it's not true okay a
suppressor will reduce the decibels of
[ __ ] any given firearm but if you're
dealing with something that is say like
supersonic bullet that is supersonic
going above we'll just say a thousand
feet per second maybe 1,100 feet per
second it's gonna make a sonic boom yeah
whether the report is silenced or
suppressed or not okay what ends up
happening is something like a subsonic
9-millimeter suppress sounds like an
unsuppressed 22 yeah a suppressed say
ak-47 all right
with regular ammunition in it it's not
quiet you know you may not have to wear
your plugs when you're shooting it but
it's kind of like a kind of like an
unsuppressed nine-millimeter you know so
it sounds like a pistol instead of a
rifle yeah it just reduces it the only
thing that I've really heard that was
really [ __ ] like man that was [ __ ]
quiet okay it's things like 22 caliber
suppressed press pretty damn quiet yeah
a little bit more than a BB gun but not
all this [ __ ] is irrelevant it doesn't
have any impact on crime yeah because
you could take a suppressed 9-millimeter
and shoot somebody in a house and the
neighbors not here yeah but you could
take an unsuppressed nine-millimeter to
shoot somebody in the house and the
neighbors not here
yeah so it's kind of pointless kind of
pointless okay which that's what I
thought was kind of amusing about this
story was that he he really wanted to be
going to a career as a hitman but the
wreath but because the silencer wasn't
as quiet as you that kind of like dashed
his hitman dreams yeah he decided he
couldn't do it you could shoot
unsuppressed 22 long-rifle in your house
all day long your neighbors won't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing yeah so what
good is a suppressor yeah it's mostly
just because you don't have to wear
earplugs but you know doesn't anything
to do with hiding the fact that shots
are fired right they don't hide the fact
that shots are fired and [ __ ] people
won't know shots are fired even
unsuppressed under under most
circumstances anyway like if you're
dealing with inside a house which would
be like an assassination yes type
situation you don't need the suppressor
yeah and in public people are gonna see
you shooting you know it doesn't matter
it doesn't mean it's no impact on crime
yeah so these are wannabe yeah these
wannabe assassins but buy that [ __ ] and
they think it's gonna be some kind of a
game-changing piece of technology it
will not make an impact on the shooting
yeah like I said I think that's that out
went oh [ __ ] well I guess I can't be a
hitman yeah yeah yeah I thought it was
gonna be like completely silent cuz like
I said he's not like this the brightest
ball yeah so he gets back to the u.s.
still using the name John O'Leary he
actually goes to the u.s. customs office
in New York and he renewed his captain's
license now obviously his yacht the
akisto had been had crashed but what he
was planning to do was he was gonna go
up like the the coast line and stuff
like that and he was gonna try and find
another yacht that looked like that
yacht and steal it and then say that
that was his boat you know what I mean
like he was gonna repaint it and like me
the name on [ __ ] like that so that's
what he was planning to do so while Carl
is going up the East Coast on his quest
to find a boat that looks enough like
the akisto that he could pass it off as
his he ends up in Salem Massachusetts
now while he's in Salem and this is
another direct quote from
mr. panzram he says you will find that I
have consistently followed one idea
through all my life I prayed upon the
weak the harmless and the unsuspecting
hmm so you know yeah so while he's in
Salem he's walking around the streets
and he spots an 11 or 12 year old boy
named George Henry McMahon now he had
actually been sent on an errand on this
particular day like to go to a store and
buy something for his aunt who owned a
restaurant so apparently Carl sees him
and he walks up to the kid and he says
hey I have like a job for you you want
to earn 50 cents so the kid said sure
then he takes the kid on a trolley ride
and they go on the trolley and then they
end up like in a part of town that's
kind of deserted then he says I grabbed
him by the arm and told him I was going
to kill him I stayed with the boy about
three hours during that time I committed
sodomy on the boys six times and then I
killed him by beating his brains out
with a rock I had stuffed down his
throat several sheets of paper out of a
magazine
so yeah that's nice I'm like I said the
kid was just [ __ ] like doing an
errand for his aunt or something so he
covers the body up with tree branches
and then gets the [ __ ] out of town um
now it happens that while he was running
out of town or like bond he was running
out of the woods brief where he hid the
body to locals actually saw him now they
didn't the kid's body wasn't found until
two or three days later so they didn't
know that they had just seen like a
murder you know happened or that he was
a murderer
but that would kind of come back into
play later those two people that had
seen him like running out they just
thought they'd remember him because of
how he looked and like that he looked
like suspicious because he looked like
really nervous and stuff so then Carl
goes back to New York and as I said you
know the the kid's body was actually
found three days later and they had
arrested like a bunch of people and
pedophiles and [ __ ] like that but um you
know for a long time it would not be
solved so after he left Salem he goes
back to Westchester County
he's still looking for a boat that he
can pass off as his boat now he actually
rented an apartment in Yonkers New York
under his alias John O'Leary and got a
job as a watchman at a mill company now
while he worked at this mill he said
that he met a fifteen year old boy named
George Willison I guess is how you
pronounce his last name and of this
particular teenager he said I started to
teach him the fine art of sodomy but I
found he had been taught all about it
and he liked it fine damn now apparently
I don't know if he killed this kid but
he traveled with this kid for a little
while so summer of 1923 he goes to
Providence Rhode Island and stole a boat
out of a marina so this was actually a
pretty nice boat it was 38 feet long and
had like really good [ __ ] in it he set
sail for Long Island Sound because he
was very familiar with that area so
while he was like and because he had
done a bunch of murders there before so
he basically did the same thing again he
goes back to New Haven he stalks the
boat there and then he would go out at
night in the bars like looking for
people to rape and rob he would go
looking for houses to burgle and whatnot
he ended up stealing another 38 and he
actually stole that the 38 that he stole
was like on this boat and the boat ended
up being owned by the police
commissioner like yeah yeah so I don't
think he knew that at the time but yeah
okay so he goes up to Yonkers on this
boat he picks up George Poulos and the
teenager that I've been traveling with
him in he told this kid that you know
I'll give you some work on the yacht and
everything like that in whatever so they
go up to Kingston Karl he you know put
the boat in her marina there or in a bay
he repainted the whole to make it look
like his old boat and changed the name
on there and then he said that he was
gonna like sell it to somebody so he
goes around looking for a buyer
apparently I don't think that was what
he really wanted to do but so he comes
across this guy that says he wants to
buy his yacht so the guy light comes out
to look at the
boat and then Carl's like hey why don't
we have a drink or something like that
so they're on the boat now the funny
thing about well it's not funny but it's
like the weird thing about this was that
this guy comes onto the boat like he
pretends he's gonna buy it and then that
guy tried to rob Carl yeah but Carl had
already I mean because I guess he was
like a hardened criminal and he was like
suspicious so he actually got the drop
on the guy because he's like yeah I
thought this guy was acting kind of
sketchy so he ended up getting the drop
on him and shot the man twice in the
head so that guy was like actually
trying to hold him up
ironically yeah so that's one of the
stories the story I heard is that he
just said that yeah but you know what it
really doesn't I feel like that probably
did happen because like other times the
people were completely innocent and he
didn't have any compunctions about
telling people that he just [ __ ]
there for no reason
why would he lie so why would he lie
about that guy you know like that one
guy in particular true so yeah he's so
he shoots this guy in the head and then
ties like a weight to his body and
throws him off and he later said he's
still there yet as far as I know money
was still there so George Willison had
actually seen the killing and I don't
know I guess he wasn't like really
worried about it that's the boy thing
that's the boy that he's been traveling
with yeah so I got a boyfriend yeah kind
of so so they go down river they dock in
Poughkeepsie Karl goes on shore and
steals about a thousand dollars worth of
fishing nets and then they kind of you
know they kept going on to Newburgh now
after the boat dropped anchor at this
one particular port the kid jumped off
the ship and swam to shore okay and went
back to Yonkers and went to the cops
okay and said that Karl had raped him
okay so um the Yonkers police like set
out like a bulletin like looking for
that he must not liked it as much as
Carl said that's what I'm saying I don't
the kid wasn't going willingly I don't
think I think that I mean it was only a
feral kid and he might have been like
terrified to the dude as you know
understandably so he might have just
think he might have just been going
along like to keep from getting killed
or whatever his first opportunity jumped
off
and report into the cops so you know at
this point the kid only knew him is
Captain John O'Leary so that's the name
that went out over the wire that the
person that they were looking for so
Karl ends up getting two Nyack New York
and the cops actually caught him there
they boarded the yacht because they knew
what the boat looked like and everything
like that so he gets charged with sodomy
burglary and robbery and they he goes
and gets picked up so they put him in
the city jail and July 2nd 1923 tried to
break out of there with another prisoner
who was named Fred Federoff they tried
to pry the window bars out of the frames
by digging up the masonry like I said
that was something that he did a lot
however they were caught when guards
were going around making a routine
inspection of the cells so that's sorry
I just saw the catchy jokes like out of
the curtains so they they called him a
river pirate at this point is what they
were calling him so he got solitary
confinement
then he hires a lawyer named mr. cash
and what he did was he told the lawyer
he said okay well I have a yacht that's
worth five to ten thousand dollars which
was stolen obviously right and he said
if you get me out of jail then I'll give
you the yacht in all the papers
right so the attorney like succeeds and
like gets him bail and Carl gets out of
print gets out of jail and then he takes
off now he did leave the yacht in the
papers with the lawyer but the lawyer
tries to get registered the boat and
finds out it was stolen so yeah so you
know it's it's kind of funny so um yeah
so anyway so Carl goes to this place
called Larchmont which was kind of like
an upper-class like Yacht Club type of
place in Connecticut and well
Westchester County I guess it was
Connecticut naor upstate New York
whatever so he steals another boat in
Larchmont and marina he stole it
therefore it was a doctor's boat
now this boat he actually I guess that
he had lost rudder control and ended up
crashing it into the rocks
a few days later he broke into the
Larchmont train depot and he found an
axe in there and he busted open a window
and there was like all these suitcases
in there that I guess like people that
were going on a train journey the next
day had like sent their luggage ahead so
he went through all the luggage it was
like stealing [ __ ] out of everyone's
luggage like in this [ __ ] train depot
now a cop who was going around like you
know making his rounds or whatever which
to evoke so a guy's making his
early-morning rounds and he pierced
through the window and sees [ __ ] Carl
and they're like going through
everybody's suitcases and [ __ ] so he
like you know kind of gets the drop on
him and we'll see it's like covering the
gun and everything now the then there
was like a big fight because obviously
Carl isn't gonna be taken so he kind of
gets up and starts struggling with the
cop but they you know they got in a big
fight and then the officer ended up
disarming him and they put him under
arrest he said that his name was John
O'Leary and he got charged with three
burglaries and I think like one other
like break-in but no ray no because they
hadn't I guess they didn't charge him
for that or they didn't believe like the
kid when he said I mean I don't know
it's like really where they figured well
is no way to really prove that that's
yeah maybe you know and we got him all
these other charges and he'll go down
for that might have been something like
that yeah so here's the thing I feel
like at this point Carl was maybe sick
of running away from the law or was just
kind of like sick of everything or
something because he was only charged
with these burglaries right like his
bail was set at $5,000 but he goes to
the county jail and while he's in the
jail he tells the cops there I'm an
escaped prisoner from Oregon where I was
serving a 17 year sentence for shooting
a police officer right so he just told
him like straight out didn't ask him or
nothing like that now the cops didn't
really believe him at first he was what
they called he they thought that he was
what they called a chiseler which was a
person
who just would commit to crimes like
that or would um you know it confess to
crimes that he didn't commit just so he
could get like moved to another place or
like moved to a better facility or
something like that so even though they
didn't they said well you know maybe
maybe we should check that out so they
sent a telegram to the cops in Oregon
and very shortly afterward they got a
letter back from the Larchmont you know
from the warden of the Oregon State
Penitentiary that said Jeff Baldwin
which was the name that Carl was going
by an Oregon is wanted very badly in
Oregon his was a noted case that
attracted considerable attention all
over the Pacific coast and we are very
anxious to send an officer for him at
the earliest possible moment so the cops
and in Larchmont were kind of like oh
well I guess he wasn't bullshitting they
really are looking for a stupid ass so
he why he confessed to that I don't know
I like I said maybe he was just sick of
running around because he couldn't stay
anywhere that damn sadomasochism maybe
he likes to be punished yeah yeah so why
are you biting she's trying to eat the
box but yeah so he still had 14 years
left on his sentence in Oregon now this
is how cheeky this [ __ ] bastard was
because there was a $500 reward for his
capture he tried to get it yeah because
he said well y'all wouldn't know and if
I didn't tell you
right yes basically like about the
Oregon thanks a week trying to collect
the reward for his own I canif like holy
crap and of course they were like um no
nice try yes so um so at this stage it's
probably like um as I said maybe he was
just sick of running around and he just
figured well you know this is the end of
the road for me or whatever so he ends
up a couple weeks later he gets indicted
for the Larchmont burglary and he cut a
deal with the DA's office
in that this is kind of the same thing
that happened again where he said the D
said oh if you plead guilty you'll get a
lighter sentence so he did that but it
didn't work out like he got five years
and this was just LAN on like a burglary
charge so he gets five years which was
the maximum and he gets sent to singsing
however because he was a trouble
prisoner they actually sent him upstate
to another prison Clinton prison which
was more equipped to deal with difficult
prisoners so he wasn't it same thing
very long now Clinton prison was better
known as Dannemora or the hellhole and
it was kind of again this was another
prison that had a reputation for being
like one of the worst of the worst you
know what I mean just like horrible
conditions you know just all the
prisoners were beaten tortured
everything like that this is the place
that I was talking about earlier that
had the State Hospital for the
criminally insane was like right across
the courtyard so it's like when the
conditions at Dannemora like drove one
of the inmates crazy they would just
take you and dump you over there and
like I said the end none of the inmates
wanted to go to the mental hospital
because that was even worse conditions
than the prison was now so karl was in
this place for a few weeks and he
decided he was going to build a bomb and
burn down the workshops at the prison
however the bomb was found by the guards
before he could carry out his plan he
also tried to kill one of the guards
while the guard was sleeping in a chair
hitting him on the back of the head with
a ten pound Club it didn't kill him
though although it did hurt him very
badly obviously he was only there so
karl was there for a few months and he
tried to escape now this was the escape
where he basically he climbed one of the
prison walls and then fell 30 feet like
onto a concrete step he boat he broke
both his legs and both his ankles and
[ __ ] up his
spine okay we have heard it he didn't
climb a wall that he went out of window
yeah but you know I don't know it's one
of the - one of the other yeah sometimes
stuff I think is parsley legend there
depends oh he broke all these bones and
they didn't really do any medical
treatment they just like kind of scooped
him out of the courtyard and just like
threw him back in his cell like with a
brook they didn't like set his broken
bones or anything like that okay so he
didn't go on the run with broken bones
no okay that was a story I heard it must
know he he busted his back in his legs
and then they just came back and they
didn't set any of the bones that they
never healed properly all right so he
was so he was left like that for 14
months before they took him to a
hospital and at this point they I was
kind of laughing because like last
podcast on the left they were talking
about when he fell and like broke you
know his bones and stuff they also said
that he had like a rupture and then the
guy was like do they mean that like his
butthole fell out of his little later
lapse and it's like I'm not sure if
that's what it was cuz it did kind of
sound like that's what they were hinting
at but it's like yeah so his bones are
all [ __ ] up but he did they didn't
take him to hospital for like more than
a year they were trying to kill him and
then when they yeah and then when they
did take him he got operated on for the
rupture
yeah and they took one of his testicles
out okay so like I said and this was the
time where like they took one of the
testicles out and then like right after
that they found him raping another
inmate because he was trying to see like
if it still worked or not
I guess because like after they took the
testicle out so yeah and this is what he
said about this time period he said I
suffered more agony for many months
always in pain never a civil answer from
anyone always a snarl or a curse or a
lying hypocritical promise which was
never kept crawling around like a snake
with a broken back seething with hatred
and a lust for revenge five years of
this kind of life the last two years and
four months confined in isolation with
nothing to do except brood yeah
so during this period probably
understandably I guess because he was in
constant pain he had not had any medical
attention for his injuries
he basically started thinking about
terrorist plots
um he was going to yet plan to like blow
up a railroad tunnel when a train was
going through it and then like once the
train wrecked he was gonna like spray
poison gas in there like to kill anybody
that had survived he planned to dynamite
a bridge in New York and then Rob the
people that you know were dying he was
gonna blow up the Panama Canal he was
gonna poison the water supply in the
nearby village you know he was so he was
thinking of that type of stuff he just
wanted to wipe out [ __ ] everybody
that's how much he hated the entire
human race right so he served five years
at Dannemora and was let out now
obviously he was permanently crippled
but so yeah so he was sent out free
within two weeks after his release he
had already committed 12 burglaries and
killed one man during a robbery in
Baltimore he got arrested again and then
sent to jail in Washington DC like I
said very scary dude at this point even
though he walked with a decided limp
kind of like a weird Skippy kind of walk
you know he's big [ __ ] burly dude he
had a big [ __ ] sailor tattoo like on
his chest and he was bald and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so um while he was
there this was actually the first time I
think when he was arrested where he
actually gave his real name - like the
prison guards so while he's in the DC
jail within a few days he starts making
some remarks about killing children
which kind of you know got the guards
attention and so they started asking
around about him in other states and
found out like about all of his other
crimes now this part of the story is
very interesting and there was actually
kind of a movie was made about this that
I think had James Woods in it so at this
jail that he was at at this time period
there was a guard who had just started
he was only 26 years old and his name
was Henry
and for some reason lessor kind of felt
sorry for carl panzram and was actually
the only person that was like nice to
him and interestingly him being nice to
cut like carl was like freaked out
because i think that no one had ever
been nice to him ever and so like Henry
lesser like gave him a dollar one day
like for like some cigarettes or some
extra food or something like that and
Carl was like really like touched by
that because no one had been nice to him
ever like his entire life
I remember hearing about the guy don't
know if I saw an interview with him or
or somebody was just talking about it
he was he was a new guard and he didn't
really like what was going on in there
yeah he was very much into like you
really need to like be nice to me seems
like this is not how you handled it yeah
these these guys and panzram got his
[ __ ] ass but they've made beat his
ass one yeah and when the guys when the
guards who did it left he went up he
went up to the bars and he gave him some
money and said that in told us that he
didn't believe that they should have
done that to him yeah and bought him
canteen you know yeah out of the store
and panzram was grateful for it now if I
remember correctly this guard ended up
years later being in charge of the dam
performing the prison systems I wouldn't
know if he did or not that's how I
remember it he ended up being like in
charge of the prison systems of that
state
yeah but much later on yeah but that
might just be my memory you know that's
just you know I do these shows mostly
from memory I remember he was some kind
of a prison reformer yeah
and that he ended up kind of like that's
how I remember it he ended up and
[ __ ] you know bringing humanity back
to prison but part of Carl's problem is
that from a little kid man he had as
humanity just like a stripped from him
well everyone treated him like a [ __ ]
wild animal yeah and then that's why he
acted like yeah and it was kind of like
a vicious cycle yeah ya know so I mean
you can't treat people like that and
expect
he's got worse and worse and I mean
obviously he proud he had other problems
too because a lot of people were
mistreated in that particular way not
all of them ended up like he ended up
obviously so he had to have something
different about him like I said could
have been the head injury maybe he had
some psychopathic tendencies or
something like that doesn't make sure of
everything but yeah so but it does seem
like and there was another thing too and
I'm not exactly sure where this is in
the timeline but apparently there was
one warden at one prison that he was at
it might have been the same one I'm not
really sure but it wasn't this guy it
was the warden and this warden was very
into you know this whole torturing the
prisoners and should this is just not
working out it's like you know they're
just out of control and so he thought
that it would be better to give
prisoners like privilege like treat them
like human beings yeah and so what he
would do was he would let Carl out like
during the day he said you can go out
during the day and do whatever you want
to as long as you come back here like by
6:00 p.m. or whatever time it was and
like everyone thought he was nuts now it
did end up like not working later
because later Carl was like it's he just
decided he would leave but Carl actually
did come back later several dates like
he left the prison and like went and
drank in a bar or whatever like all day
and then he but he came back yeah and so
like I said after a few days like he was
at a bar and he thought well I'm kind of
having fun and I guess if I don't go
back to the prison I can just have fun
like this all the time so I think I'll
just leave but it did work for a few
days like he did actually come back to
the prison of his own volition yes
that's a little too much free right
probably that's a little much best way
to do it is do things like give him give
him privileges a better housing and
stuff and let him have access to certain
things yeah and if they [ __ ] up you take
it away yeah so they always have
something to lose I definitely do feel
like it's better to like reward them for
right for good behavior than punishing
them for bad baby because punished
thinking for but you're basically just
like I said you treat them like a wild
animal that's how they're gonna behave I
mean yes there are some people that are
probably there's nothing you can do
about them I mean there we've talked
about some of on the show
some guys you know goat they're natural
instinct is to fight back yeah and
that's if you keep beating them they're
going to
and that's exactly what this guy did
yeah it's like Carl I feel like he got
beat on and raped and [ __ ] like that his
whole life it's like he didn't really
have much of a chance he's at war with
the world and he's yeah and that's
basically how he sees it he knows that
he's gonna get tortured he knows he's
gonna get punished when he does it but
he does it anyway just because he can't
he's so angry and he just can't stop
himself and he couldn't behave and
become a normal part of society now with
the history that he had right so what
you know it's you to get a job yeah yeah
so you know yeah he was just gonna be a
prison yeah so well I mean while he's up
this prison they should have done to him
is kept him in a [ __ ] good prison
kept him in institutionalized give him a
little job there in the prison
privileges and that's how you control
him mr. dick and carrot yeah yeah they
need man I mean obviously just like
torturing them and doing the horror [ __ ]
that they did to the prisoners at this
point that was not helping anything
clearly and it wasn't helping him it
didn't fix anything did it he just got
worse and worse and you know and
particularly at this prison you know
other than Henry lesser who was just one
guard who he actually befriended I mean
Carl was getting true he's trying to
escape and [ __ ] like that and like I
said they would [ __ ] you know they
would do that [ __ ] thing where they'd
tie him up to he you know his only his
toes are touching the floor and they
leave him like that for days and you
know [ __ ] [ __ ] up their shoulders
and all this other kind of crap you know
he gets beaten into unconsciousness and
tied to a pole and all this other kind
of crap and then so at this point like
Carl says that you know he confessed to
a bunch of murders of like young boys
and he told the guards that he really
enjoyed it and [ __ ] like that he
confessed to the murder of a
fourteen-year-old named alexander
leather kit was in Philadelphia and he
confessed to the murder of Henry McMahon
in Salem so at this point he just
started confessing to everything he
confess to all the murders and
everything like that so at this point
like I said you know Henry lesser is
kind of like befriended him you know
giving him money and kind of taking pity
on him and he's encouraging him you know
why don't you write your life story down
so he actually brought him like a pencil
and paper and got them you know got him
to start writing everything down so it
just seems very strange that
as I said this one act of kindness the
one person in his whole life that had
been nice to him really got him to open
up about [ __ ] Henry lesser actually
after Carl died Henry lesser carried
this [ __ ] manuscript that he had
written around for like forty years like
trying to look for a publisher and no
one would publish it until like 40 years
later yeah so he tried for 40 years to
get it published but it it's interesting
too because there was another guy like a
psychologist dr. Karl Menninger who
Menninger who was actually quite well
known and he was kind of more into
psychoanalysis and he was kind of
interested in prison reform and things
like that so he really wanted to talk to
Karl Panzer because he found him an
interesting specimen so he actually did
go and meet with Karl but Karl would not
really talk to him he was like really
kind of hostile hmm so that didn't
really work out so good so but basically
he did like I said Karl did really seem
to have a handle on the institutions of
the prisons and the reform schools and
everything like that making people like
him you know obviously all of the blame
you know some of the blame is on him
because he did make particular decisions
about what he did and stuff like that
once he was an adult but considering
that most of his life since he was a
child had been spent in these conditions
it's very it's not very surprising that
he turned out the way he turned out he
pretty much said that the only rule he
ever learned was might makes right and
he said and this is a quote from his
book too he said in my lifetime I've
broken every law that was ever made by
both man and God if either had made any
more I should very cheerfully have
broken them also so yeah now again it
just seemed like as much as he knew he
would get punished like I said he was
just very he kept getting thrown in
solitary he kept getting beaten but he
still would not submit he would not
submit to the rules he was always
violent
always uncooperative he got struck in
the head with a blackjack for attacking
three officers you know [ __ ] like that
so at this point he gets charged with
yet another murder which was a guy named
Alexander Zaki who he had killed in 1928
and at this point they'd also like had
all of the confession that he had like
all the people that he ended up
murdering which he says was 21 that he
could remember and he seemed to have a
very good memory about [ __ ] and like I
said when they looked into the cases
that he talked about it wasn't just
[ __ ] he did have you know they did
find evidence of it and [ __ ] like that
so so he wasn't just blowing smoke so at
this stage sets he's confessed all this
stuff they're like okay well he knows at
this point that he's not getting out of
jail at this stage so I think at this
point he had just kind of come to the
end of the rope and he's just like [ __ ]
it I just I want to die because what
ended up happening was that even like
when he when they tried him like for
some of the murders and stuff like that
and he ended up getting a death sentence
and there were some groups that were
trying to abolish the death penalty and
they wanted to intervene on his behalf
and he wrote them a very very angry
letter telling them to [ __ ] off
essentially because he wanted to die
yeah he did not want an appeal he did
not want anything
he wrote the president I think told him
not to [ __ ] interfere or somebody
like that it's like he wrote like it
really yeah yeah so yes so he goes back
to Leavenworth and at this point he is
put on death row now as soon as he comes
into the prison the first thing he says
to the warden is I'll kill the first man
that bothers me yeah so they actually
they didn't want to mix him with the
general population what he would leave
alone stop it though she's playing with
the crazy-ass paper trying to kill the
Christmas baby
don't kill the paper so she goes and
kills the papers yeah she thinks I'm
egging it on yeah she's like oh boo he
goes yeah yeah yeah so um they thought
that he didn't really mix
the general population because they
thought that he was too crazy too
dangerous they did put him like on a
certain job but he actually wanted a
different job Podrick I don't yeah I
don't really like people so can you put
me in a job like by myself so they put
him in the prison laundry yeah so he
could work by himself however um there
he also had a supervisor whose name was
Robert warnky and Robert Markey was
another super hard-ass and Karl [ __ ]
hated him yeah so you knew this was
gonna go badly yeah oh yeah so it's like
having a kid it is yeah she's gonna come
back yeah
come here don't be a maggot Danny's
letter that there don't come here that's
fine she's happy yeah okay Glen finish
it
all right so June 20th 1929 Karl is in
the laundry and he notices that right
there leaning against the door is a four
foot long iron bar damn they were stupid
to leave that there weren't they yeah he
bright but that there were his own
protection
maybe he did I don't know I think it was
like used for something else but it's
like I don't
so basically Karl just strolls right on
over there picks up the iron bar and
bumped him right in those the [ __ ]
wailed on this dude's [ __ ] skull yeah
supposedly saying here's another one for
you you son of a [ __ ] broke his skull
with the first blow yeah now apparently
like after the dude fell and he was
already dead the dude just kept [ __ ]
wailing on his blood and brains like
flying [ __ ] everything know better
than to be an [ __ ] man dude you
panzram had nothing to lose that's what
is holy come on okay look up more people
what are they gonna do yeah yeah
so yeah so a bunch of like other inmates
like saw this and we're [ __ ]
terrified because he was basically like
waving it at everybody like a bat
everybody ran the [ __ ] away from him
they let him go back into his cell like
he just went back into his cell very
calmly and just sat on the bed yeah it
was like yep I just killed that dude
whatever like just covered with blood
and [ __ ] like that so they can do thing
to him yeah well yeah what they couldn't
kill them with their own hands he was
sentenced to die how he couldn't cover
that
yeah covered up stages okay whatever
yeah he was on his way out anyway true
Fred Earp I like what that dudes a
[ __ ] and you know what yeah it's like
you know what I think is I think I mess
up the timeline a little bit I don't
even think he had that cuz I think he
got the death sentence for killing that
guy is it that though I don't even think
that he had the death sense he was in
for a bunch of other [ __ ] so he just
decided he was gonna kill but he had
already I mean he knew that he wasn't
getting out because he would confess to
a bunch of stuff and they had like lined
at all that's true what you think a guy
good once you once you think of guys the
death sentence they probably figure he's
so dangerous he has to stay in his cell
yeah yeah I mean the thing is like they
they still have like a lot of letters
that he wrote to Henry lesser like
during this time period and he basically
talked a lot about like his time in jail
and he's like oh the food's okay and I
you know I feel like a human more like a
human in here than I did when I was out
and [ __ ] like that and he said that you
know I guess after that happened no one
really [ __ ] with him which I guess was
kind of happy you know it made him kind
of happy so then he goes on trial for a
Robert Warren Keys murder eventually
this was in 1930 he decided to serve as
his own defense like I said I think at
this point he just wanted to get it all
over with because they asked him you
know do you have an attorney and he said
no I don't want one you know but he did
come in and he said I plead not guilty
now you go ahead and prove me guilty
understand
so he's like [ __ ] yeah cheeky so um
you know they have all these [ __ ]
witnesses all the guards all the other
inmates they all come in and they
testify against him it took 45 minutes
for the jury to come in and go guilty as
[ __ ] and he'll be hanged
yeah in 1930 apparently when he got the
death sentence he seemed relieved
yeah um seems good now yeah they said
that what he said after he got the death
sentence he they said a huge smile went
across his face and he said I certainly
want to thank you judge just let me get
my fingers around your neck for 60
seconds and you'll never sit on another
bench as judge yeah so you know yeah so
as I said that there were a lot of you
know people who wanted to abolish the
death penalty they were trying to help
him
you know we're trying to help you get a
sense or help him with an appeal or
something like that
however he said I want to be hanged and
I don't want any interference by you or
your filthy kind
I just know more about the world in the
essential evil nature of man and I don't
play the hypocrite I'm proud of having
killed off a few and regret that I
didn't kill more so he said that to one
of the psychologists though that was
talking about talking to him
the another interesting thing about him
is that he was in prison with the very
famous Birdman of Alcatraz Robert Stroud
yeah now Robert Stroud later in his own
like memoirs he actually said that he
thought carl panzram was full of [ __ ]
but they actually didn't know each other
that well i think some sources that i
saw it like said they were cellmates
that that's not the case they were in
the same prison um but i don't think
they knew each other all that well why
do you think he was full of [ __ ] did he
say not really um he you know I I think
he just thought that he was like an
egomaniac and I was like making stuff up
I don't know so um yeah so as I said he
was very excited to get the death
sentence a death sentence his quote was
I look forward to a seat in the electric
chair or dance at the end of a rope just
like some folks do for their wedding
night mm-hmm yeah so uh again when one
of these groups of you know death
penalty like opponents like wrote to him
like about his case and stuff he wrote
back to them and said the only thanks
you and your kind will ever get from me
for your efforts on my behalf is that I
wish you all had one neck and that I had
my hands on it yeah I have no desire
whatever to reform myself my only desire
is to reform people who try to reform me
and I believe that the only way to
reform people is to kill him yeah yeah
it's at war with humanity yeah yeah and
you're right you did actually write to
you the president he was Herbert Hoover
at the time he said that he was
perfectly satisfied with my trial in the
sentence I do not want another trial I
absolutely refuse to accept either a
pardon or a commutation should either or
the other be offered to me so yeah so on
the morning of September 5th 1930 carl
panzram was taken from his cell for the
last time and escorted to the gallows
he yeah he cursed his own mother for
bringing him into the world and cursed
the whole damned human race so there was
the whole damn human he almost they said
that he actually kind of briskly like
walked up to the gallows like he was
like super jazzed about it he study goes
up to the platform and they asked him if
he had any last words and his last words
were hurry up you Hoosier bastard I
could kill ten men while you're full
fingerprint
what's a Hoosier somebody from Indiana
okay oh and also he spit in the
executioner's face okay so you know so
yeah they hanged him Oh [ __ ] hell man
can you believe that was his last [ __ ]
I mean it's funny because like I was
listening to last podcast on the left
and you could tell that it's like they
were like this is like a horrible dude
but it's like also kind of a badass
oh yeah well he was just created in a
[ __ ] shitstorm of [ __ ] suffering
yeah and hatred so you know he was at
war with mankind and he got sick of it
yeah and was like I'm out of here yeah
really okay yeah like he really didn't
he really didn't and and just live with
it really by did just the defiance that
he sure just wanted to leave man he
wanted to leave yeah maybe I can't blame
him and like I said I think that that's
probably why when he got arrested for
some minor [ __ ] like why he started
confessing yeah to all of this stuff
which is because he's just like it
probably wears on you over after a while
I mean he was like 36 years old at this
point and he had spent like most of his
life like running away you know what I
mean he couldn't stay anywhere you
couldn't even [ __ ] up in some prison
and then you know ran and killing people
all the time you know in this war
against humans
yeah and he's gay if he asked me yeah
probably I don't think he hasn't really
well-defined about what that means you
know yeah it's just maybe in a weird way
all that rape made him gay or something
I don't know yeah he doesn't have any
interest in women no he never even
really mentioned it you would think that
if it you would think that because one
of them what are you doing why are you
acting crazy she's like you're not
paying attention you would think that
because one of his quotes was this you
know well it's not sexual it's just it's
just dominance yeah but if that was true
then that means he'd go after women too
yeah you would think yeah so I'm not
really buying that and like I said it
seemed like he never even mentioned
didn't you mention women no interest at
all he really didn't you just that what
and then like why go after little kids
yeah
they hadn't done anything to him
betrayal so you know yeah that was his
sexual orientation but yeah I mean this
was a dude that basically so I meant
burn into him when he was a kid what I
mean one of his quotes was I hate all
the [ __ ] human race he just hated
everybody he hated himself and he was
just like just took it upon himself as a
mission to like just [ __ ] kill as
many I don't know agreement that I
believe he hated men yeah I think he
hated man cuz those are the ones that
[ __ ] him up yeah I mean I guess other
than his mom who he said he wasn't like
super fond of her but it's kind of like
when fond of her cuz she couldn't save
him yeah it's it's interesting though
because it seems like a lot of serial
killers kill women you know because
that's you know who they're sexually
oriented toward but also because it's
almost like they're trying to punish
their mom yeah
to like cuz they hate their mom and
they're like taking it out what women at
large I think he saw it is that he had a
weak mom that was it had no effect so
because she had no effect on anything he
just forgot about it yeah I could I I
feel like it's almost kind of like women
who were like beneath his notice
yeah yeah that's definitely what it
seems like yeah but yeah alright so we
probably gone on long enough I'm sure
there was a lot of details I left out
because oh there's just so much this
dude is like so [ __ ] crazy yeah but
yeah so hopefully you guys enjoyed our
drunken rambling discussion with all
overcount running around breaking
everything stop the show I know you guys
doing you guys need to come play with me
so we shoot we we should probably go
play with her before she goes nuts
all right so hope you guys enjoyed 180
remember if you like the show please
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like
to financially support the show it would
be much appreciated you can get our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little PayPal button in
the sidebar if you would like to give a
one-time donation that would also be
much appreciated this has been episode
180 about carl panzram who hated the
entire [ __ ] human race yeah we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]